Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 125 von UKW.
Und wenig überraschend geht auch diese Folge wieder rund um den Konflikt in der Ukraine,
den durch Russland angezettelten Krieg auf dem Gebiet der Ukraine und neuerdings
halt auch auf dem Gebiet von Russland.
Und da muss natürlich jemand mit ins Boot, nämlich Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, wir haben wieder fleißig notiert, was alles so passiert.
Wir machen das ja immer so, dass wir uns so eine Timeline quasi merken, so eine Art Logbuch.
Kaum ist eine Sendung veröffentlicht, geht es dann schon wieder los.
Irgendwelche Nachrichten kommen rein und ich finde es immer ganz interessant,
man notiert sich dann irgendwelche Ereignisse, weil man so denkt,
da könnte was draus werden.
Also manchmal ist es ja klar, manchmal passieren einfach wichtige Sachen,
aber manchmal passieren auch so Sachen, da weiß man noch gar nicht so,
wird das jetzt einen Einfluss haben, ist da was im Busch, schreibe ich mir das
schon mal auf, nicht, dass ich das wieder vergesse.
Und später geht man durch seine Notizen und denkt sich so, ja nee,
war doch nur ein Gerücht.
Das ist so ein bisschen der Segen der verspäteten Berichterstattung.
Ich mag das immer wieder, wenn der hektische News-Cycle sich wirklich auf jede
Bewegung im Gebüsch stürzt, auch wenn da am Ende nicht viel dabei ist,
dann hat man immer dieses Problem, dass man dann irgendwann auch gar nicht mehr
weiß, worauf man jetzt eigentlich noch reagieren soll.
Und das ist,
Der Vorteil von Podcasts, wenn man nur alle paar Wochen mal was erzählt.
Wir legen sozusagen noch eine weitere Art von Filter über die News,
nämlich einen temporalen Filter,
wo wir dann so ein paar Dinge dann schon mal raus averagen können und dann eben
schon richtig sagst, nicht jedem Gerücht hinterher rennen müssen.
Aber natürlich haben wir auch ganz aktuelle Sachen drin, die dann erwähnenswert erscheinen.
Und insofern gibt es auch mal ein paar Ausschläge bei uns. Ein paar Spikes.
Genau. Letzte Sendung war vom 24. September,
zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir das hier aufnehmen. Letzte Ausgabe war vom 16.
August, also knapp fünf Wochen vergangen.
Ja, und ist irgendwas passiert? Ja, you bet.
Wir werden also wie immer mit den militärischen Entwicklungen im Krieg beginnen
und mal kurz nachzeichnen,
was sich denn so im Großen und teilweise auch im Kleinen so ergeben hat auf
dem Schlachtfeld in der unmittelbaren Auseinandersetzung zwischen Russland und der Ukraine.
Dann wollen wir ein bisschen auf Militärtechnik wieder eingehen.
Das tun wir deshalb im Übrigen, weil es eben sich gezeigt hat,
dass neue technologische Entwicklungen immer eine erhebliche Auswirkung auf diesen Krieg haben.
Also es entstammt jetzt gar nicht so aus einer äh, nerdhaften Technikbegeisterung
oder so etwas oder gar irgendeinem Waffenwahn sondern es ist einfach dieser
Krieg ist, glaube ich, mehr,
Als viele andere in den letzten Jahrzehnten von dieser technologischen Entwicklung
getrieben einerseits, aber auch geprägt, weil sich,
was weiß ich, also dass die Ukraine sich überhaupt so zur Wehr setzen kann,
ist zum Beispiel sehr dem Drohnenkrieg zu verdanken.
Es ist relevant. Es ist relevant.
Absolut. Aber natürlich stecken auch strategische Überlegungen da drin,
weil man baut sich ja auch keine Waffen für irgendetwas, wofür man keine Anwendung hat.
Genau, darauf gehen wir dann ein, dann werden wir auch nochmal genauer jetzt
auf die jüngsten Entwicklungen eingehen,
konkret die Anschläge auf die russischen Munitionsdepots, weil das schon nochmal
so ein herausragendes Ereignis zu sein scheint.
Und schauen ein bisschen auf die Politik in der Ukraine als auch international,
was da noch so passiert und wollen dann gegen Ende nochmal etwas ausführlicher
den Blick auf die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung der Ukraine und Russlands schauen,
weil das eben auch in zunehmendem Maße Teil der Debatte geworden ist,
inwiefern der Krieg jetzt für die jeweiligen Parteien noch durchzuhalten ist.
Ja, und dann liefern wir noch einen Ausblick und dann dürft ihr wieder nach Hause.
Ja, alright. Dann fangen wir doch mal an und machen da weiter,
wo wir letztes Mal aufgehört haben, nämlich mit der Kursk-Invasion.
Das war ja im Prinzip die Nachricht der letzten Sendung, dass die Ukraine einfach eine...
Die strategische Finte eingeleitet hat und den Krieg auf den Boden Russlands eröffnet hat.
Das hat die Russen überrascht. Es gab zwar viel Gerüchte darüber,
ob sie es denn nicht schon hätten besser wissen müssen oder ob sie es nicht
sogar schon besser wussten, aber keiner hat sich getraut es zu glauben oder
die Informationen nach oben weiterzureichen.
Das lässt sich aus der Ferne schwer belegen, wie es denn nun gewesen ist.
Tatsache ist, dass sie militärisch nicht sonderlich vorbereitet gewesen sind.
Das wird natürlich durch viele Faktoren begünstigt. Einerseits konzentrieren
sie sich eben auf diesen Abnutzungskrieg im sowjetischen Stil im Osten des Kriegsschauplatzes.
Andererseits haben sie halt auch so ein Problem ein bisschen mit ihrer Grenzsicherung.
Also die Grenzsicherung ist wiederum dem russischen Geheimdienst unterstellt.
Dahinter werden dann die Linien von Wehrpflichtigen abgesichert,
die natürlich schlecht ausgebildet sind und in der Regel auch sehr schlecht
behandelt werden im russischen Militär.
Ja, ich meine, wir werden eigentlich alle ziemlich schlecht behandelt im russischen
Militär, aber die Verpflichtigen nochmal besonders.
Ja, und dann war es halt auch keine Überraschung, dass die Ukraine da so einmarschieren
konnte und hat alles dran gesetzt, erstmal möglichst viel Land zu gewinnen.
Ich glaube, als wir dann die Sendung gemacht haben, war das irgendwie sowas
wie 750 Quadratkilometer Gebiet, die gesichert wurden.
Das hat sich dann in den ein, zwei Wochen danach,
in der interessanterweise Russland überhaupt keinen nennenswerten Widerstand leisten konnte,
auf tausend Quadratkilometer und vielleicht auch noch ein paar mehr erweitert.
Mittlerweile ist es wieder etwas weniger geworden.
Es sah halt erstmal so aus, als ob die Ukraine da beliebig weit voranschreiten
konnte, aber ich glaube, das war nie so unbedingt ihr Ziel, sondern es ging halt erstmal darum,
überhaupt dort Fuß zu fassen und in irgendeiner Form auch die Stellung zu halten, die man dort hat.
Und mittlerweile hat Zelensky auch gesagt, sie bleiben da, solange sie können.
Es gab dann vor allem noch diese spezifische Situation, Sie sind ja dann vorgestoßen
bis zu einer Stadt namens Corinovo und wenn Sie, oder heißt das Corinevo? Corinevo, ne?
Hätten Sie die auch noch eingenommen, dann wäre es Ihnen gelungen,
da auch wirklich ein Schloss vorzumachen.
Nämlich nicht nur vor das Gebiet, was sie gesichert haben zu dem Zeitpunkt,
sondern auch noch ein zusätzliches Gebiet von noch mal knapp 600,
700 Quadratkilometern, das nämlich einerseits,
also was quasi westlich von dem jetzt besetzten Gebiet liegt und im Westen und
im Süden an die Ukraine grenzt und im Norden.
Verläuft ein Fluss, der Sejm. Und dieser Fluss ist, wie das im Osteuropa ja
oft ist, noch so ein richtiger Fluss, der also nicht so durchbegradigt wurde,
sondern der da schön durch die Landschaft meandert.
Und obwohl er nicht im eigentlichen Sinne ein riesiger Fluss ist,
belegt dieses Feuchtgebiet, was daraus entsteht, doch eine recht große Fläche
und ist einfach für Militärequipment nicht zu überwinden, zumindest nicht so ohne weiteres.
Und es gab nur drei nennenswerte große Brücken über diesen Fluss.
Diese großen Brücken wurden dann von der ukrainischen Luftwaffe weitgehend zerstört,
sodass es eben für die Russen nicht mehr möglich war, war dieses große Gebiet von, wie gesagt,
700 Quadratkilometern überhaupt noch nennenswert zu versorgen.
Dort waren vielleicht so 3000 Soldaten eingeschlossen. Das war zumindest so
die Schätzung, die ich gehört habe.
Jetzt haben eigentlich alle so ein bisschen damit gerechnet,
dass dann die Zeit irgendwann abläuft und sich die Ukraine auch noch dieses Gebiet schnappt.
Dazu ist es tatsächlich bisher noch nicht gekommen.
Sie haben zwar hier und da einzelne Teilgebiete eingenommen,
Sind dann auch nochmal über die verschiedene Grenzstellen in dieses Gebiet eingedrungen,
aber haben es dann doch mit relativ viel Widerstand zu tun gehabt.
Entweder das oder sagen wir mal, sie waren vielleicht nicht bereit,
beliebig viele Ressourcen auf ein weiteres Vordringen zu werfen,
weil sie sich davon nicht genug ausgerechnet haben.
Letzten Endes ist ja auch die offizielle Darstellung der Ukraine die,
dass sie eben dieses Gebiet halten als Schutzschild, als Pufferzone,
um das Gebiet, um Sumi zu sichern.
Und das haben sie in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch mit diesem nicht ganz besetzten
Gebiet schon geschafft, weil dadurch, dass die Brücken zerstört sind,
kann in diesem Gebiet zumindest kein größerer Aufmarsch stattfinden.
Also ich nehme mal an, das wird alles so da ein Aspekt gewesen sein dabei.
Jetzt ist es, nachdem sich also viele russische Soldaten ergeben haben und vor
allem die Russen lange Zeit versucht haben,
das Ganze aus Reserven zu verstärken, von denen sie offensichtlich gar nicht so viel haben.
Wurde irgendwie klar, dass wenn sie dort in irgendeiner Form wieder Kontrolle
über ihre Gebiete haben wollen oder wenn sie auch nur verhindern wollen,
dass die Ukraine weiter vorschiebt, dann brauchen sie eine Verstärkung.
Und die Verstärkung haben sie dann in zunehmendem Maße von der anderen Frontlinie
abgezogen, vor allem aus dem Süden.
Also so Saporischia, die Gegend, Kherson etc.
Teile auch der Ostfront mit der großen Ausnahme ihrer derzeit aktivsten Region.
Nämlich der Vorstoß auf die Stadt Pokrovsk.
Und Pokrovsk ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr wichtige Stadt für die Ukraine.
Wenn sie die auch noch einbüßen, das wäre wirklich überhaupt nicht gut,
weil es ein wichtiger Eisenbahnbahnhof ist, ein Verteilungskreuz ist und einfach
nach Pokrovsk kommt erstmal eine ganze Weile lang nichts.
Also dann wird es schwierig größere Gebiete zu halten und deswegen hat Russland
auch erstmal davon abgesehen, von dort noch Verstärkung für Kurs zu holen.
Das scheinen sie mittlerweile etwas anders zu sehen, beziehungsweise mag es
einfach so sein, weil man jetzt merkt, dass die Offensive in Pokrovsk,
also die Offensive der Russen, etwas schwächelt.
Das kann natürlich auch sein, dass sie generell sich kurz vor so einer Kulmination,
also einer Überanstrengung der gesamten Aktivität befinden.
Das geht ja immer so in Wellen, weil man kann nicht beliebig einfach die ganze
Zeit angreifen, angreifen, angreifen, angreifen, angreifen.
Irgendwann musst du auch einfach mal wieder dich zurückziehen und Kräfte sammeln
und neu strukturieren und deine Strategie auch überdenken.
Das scheint jetzt so stattzufinden, zumal wir uns ja jetzt auch dem Herbst nähern
und das bedeutet in der Ukraine, in dieser Region vor allem Schlamm.
Ja, der Herbst hat begonnen, glaube ich jetzt schon oft. Wir befinden uns im Herbst.
Ja, aber ich habe noch nicht so viele Matsch-Videos gesehen.
Also es scheint noch nicht ganz so nass zu sein.
Kalendarisch.
Ja, also kalendarisch ist es der Herbst. Aber wenn ich jetzt Herbst sage,
dann meine ich halt eine signifikante Änderung der Wetterverhältnisse,
die dann eben in diesem lehmigen Boden dazu führt, dass dann halt einfach da
vieles nicht mehr geht, was vorher noch möglich war.
Das ist natürlich Teil der Kalkulation der Militärplaner oder sollte es zumindest sein.
Ja, du hast ja auch so verschiedene Gedanken dazu, was Putin eigentlich jetzt
dazu bewegt, dort nicht sofort zu reagieren oder also ob es ein logistisches
Problem war oder ob es ein anderes Gedankenspiel war.
Genau, ja. Ich habe mich gefragt, wie sieht Putin das jetzt einfach, diese ganze Invasion?
Und was verrät uns Putin?
Dass er das so herunterspielt eigentlich über seine Sicht der Dinge und könnte
jetzt verschiedene Hypothesen aufstellen,
nämlich dass er denkt, nee, ist eigentlich kein großes Problem.
A, B, dass er glaubt, das ist ein Riesenproblem.
Und dann könnte man noch denken, er weiß eigentlich nicht, was es jetzt ist.
Oder man kann nichts daraus schließen,
weil Putin gerade wieder 4D-Schach spielt und für uns normale Menschen,
dass sich nicht erschließt, was durch seinen Kopf geht.
Und ich bin dann zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass uns das verrät,
dass er glaubt, dass es ein großes Problem ist.
Und da gibt es halt verschiedene Menge Indikatoren. Er sah halt ziemlich unglücklich aus.
Und vor allem die Leute um ihn herum, also es gab da ja verschiedene Fernsehaufzeichnungen,
wo dann darüber geredet wurde.
Und ja, die sahen unglücklicher aus als auf jeder Beerdigung, kann man erstmal sagen.
Und dann könnte man ja auch denken, oh,
er würde das jetzt nutzen, um jetzt das Volk zu begeistern für den Krieg und
um die Rekrutierungszahlen in die Höhe zu treiben und endlich zu den Waffen zu greifen.
Und ja, stattdessen ist das Thema recht schnell wieder, nicht das Thema ist
verschwunden, aber er hat aufgehört, sich dazu zu äußern und ist erst mal auf Reisen gegangen.
Nach Aserbaidschan und Tschetschenien.
Und in beiden Ländern ist er ja für über zehn Jahre nicht gewesen.
Das heißt, da ist definitiv auch was im Busch.
Wahrscheinlich war das schon etwas länger vorbereitet. Aber ja,
wenn gerade feindliche Invasoren in dein Land reinrollen, dann ist das schon ungewöhnlich,
dann auf Reisen zu gehen.
So und ja, und deswegen glaube ich, dass ja Putin schon glaubt,
dass es ein Riesending ist.
Und ja, weil es hätte einfach nicht passieren dürfen.
Niemand hat es jetzt geglaubt, dass es passieren würde und trotzdem ist es passiert.
Das andere Ding ist, es lässt sich eigentlich nicht wirklich unter der Decke halten.
Mittlerweile hat sich das in Russland schon auch umgesprochen, was da los ist.
Und man kann sagen, dass es die Attraktivität dieses Ukraine-Krieges oder dieser
Special Military Operation nicht gerade gesteigert hat,
Sondern tatsächlich gibt es jetzt Umfragen,
wonach dieses Ereignis dazu geführt hat,
dass nur noch unter 50 Prozent es für eine gute Idee halten und es besser fänden,
wenn Russland sich aus der Ukraine zurückziehen und den Krieg beenden würde.
Was jetzt natürlich nicht bedeutet, dass das jetzt passiert oder dass es ihnen
interessiert, was diese 50 Prozent jetzt denken,
aber 75 Prozent haben das Ganze mal unterstützt in vergleichbaren Umfragen.
Das heißt, ja, es wird deutlich unpopulärer, der Krieg, oder ist deutlich unpopulärer
geworden durch diese Invasion.
Ja, also ist ein bisschen schwierig. Am Ende lautet aber der Beschluss,
dass sie dort auch versuchen dagegen zu halten und naja, das ist halt ein Dilemma
für Putin und darum geht es ja letzten Endes im Krieg.
Du willst deinem Gegner ein Dilemma auftischen, sodass du dich eigentlich nur
zwischen zwei schlechten Optionen entscheiden kannst und das ist hier auf jeden Fall gelungen.
Jetzt findet aber diese Gegenoffensive auch statt, wie schon angedeutet,
die Russen haben es dann geschafft, die Stadt Korynevo zu halten und auch die
Ukrainer am Osten ihres Vorstoßes ein bisschen zurückzudrängen,
sodass es jetzt theoretisch wieder eine Versorgungslinie gibt.
Inwiefern sie die wirklich gut nutzen können oder die nicht trotzdem noch extrem
unter Drohnenkontrolle der Ukraine liegt, das kann ich nicht einschätzen.
Aber man kann auf jeden Fall keine größeren Vorstöße mehr erwarten,
auch wenn sie dann wiederum im Westen dieses Bereiches durchaus noch Erfolge
hatten, also die Ukrainer meine ich jetzt.
Also das geht jetzt alles so ein bisschen hin und her. Am Ende wird man das sehen, wie das ausgeht.
Ich wage da ehrlich gesagt gerade gar keine richtige Voraussage zu machen.
Aber man hat halt gesehen, die Russen mussten sich doch ganz schön bewegen.
Sie haben auch teilweise Truppen aus Afrika abgezogen, um sie nach Kurs zu verlegen.
Stellt man sich jetzt die Frage, wieso Afrika, wenn das Land doch so groß ist, was soll das?
Es ist nicht nur eine reine Frage von Zahlen von Soldaten, sondern die Russen
haben halt auch das Problem,
sie brauchen halt auch für so einen Vorstoß der Ukrainer, der so gut durchgeplant
ist und der taktisch klug vorgetragen wird,
brauchen sie halt mehr als nur Waffen und irgendwie Menschenopfer.
Sondern sie brauchen halt auch mal gut ausgebildete Kämpfer,
die auch so ein bisschen ihr Handwerk auch verstehen.
Und das sind dann halt vor allem die, die in Afrika zum Einsatz kommen,
weil das sind ja dann relativ kompakte Truppen, die dort agieren und sehr gezielt
diesen afrikanischen Regimes dort helfen.
Den Umsturz durchzukriegen, wie jüngst in Niger.
Und ja, in dem Fall weiß ich, dass sie Truppen aus Burkina Faso abgezogen haben,
die stecken da halt überall drin.
Ja, aber es ist nicht gut unbedingt für die Kohäsion von Truppen,
wenn du die so auseinanderreißt und Stücke von hier nimmst und so.
Und eigentlich versucht man halt Einheiten zu bilden, die irgendwie in sich funktional sind.
Die auch sich selber versorgen können, die entsprechende Transportkapazitäten
mit haben für kurze Strecken,
die ein bestimmtes Spektrum an Waffen haben und Leute,
die die auch ein bisschen reparieren und instand halten können vor Ort und so.
Und je kleiner du natürlich die Einheit machst,
umso weniger, ich sag mal, Overhead oder Support kannst du dann jetzt haben
und das macht die ganze Logistik und alles auch nicht gerade einfacher und insbesondere natürlich Truppen,
die mit anderen Truppen noch nicht zusammengekämpft haben, das kann daneben
auch immer zu Problemen führen oder zusätzlich zu Friktionen.
Also das hat in der Tat, glaube ich, auch erstmal die Effizienz der russischen
Armee nochmal weiter reduziert, indem sie gezwungen wurden,
eine ganze Menge Änderungen schnell vorzunehmen und das ist immer nicht gut. Das ist nicht gut.
Ja, die politischen Auswirkungen der ganzen Offensive für Russland auf jeden Fall eher negativ.
Es wird irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig über diese ganzen Friedenskonferenzen geredet.
Also nicht, dass es nicht noch irgendjemand in den Mund nimmt,
aber das Thema ist so ein bisschen raus, weil ein einfriertes Konflikt bedeutet
jetzt quasi auch Verzicht von russischem Gebiet.
Auch wenn Putin alles dafür tut, nicht so rüber zu kommen, dass es ihn gar nicht interessiert.
Und ich glaube, am Ende interessiert es ihn auch nicht. Man muss sich ja auch
mal anschauen, wie die Russen jetzt versuchen, die Ukraine aus ihrem Land zu
verdrängen. Sie machen das auf dieselbe Art und Weise, wie sie versuchen,
die Ukraine einzunehmen.
Bomben auf die Dörfer, immer feste drauf. Und was sie überhaupt nicht interessiert
ist, dass da irgendwie Russen leben, die da Häuser haben. Das wird einfach alles
platt gemacht, egal, Hauptsache die Ukraine ist raus.
Dieses Denken, ich sehe das immer wieder, was mich am Anfang sehr überrascht
hat, wo ich glaube auch, weil wir einfach so gar nicht auf uns schauen.
Wir sind ja immer so ein Staat und der Staat sind die Bürger.
Und in Russland ist es halt mehr, der Staat ist die Regierung und die Regierung
herrscht über ein Territorium, auf dem sich Menschen befinden.
Und die Menschen, die auf diesem Territorium sind, mit denen muss man halt irgendwie klarkommen.
Ein bisschen Demokratiesimulation betreiben, aber eigentlich haben die alle
nichts zu melden und das merkt man halt in solchen Fällen dann extrem.
Es hat natürlich auch Druck auf die USA ausgeübt und auf Europa jetzt endlich
mal ein bisschen klar zu kommen und da mal diese ganzen Restriktionen aufzuheben.
Also noch vor ein paar Monaten hatten wir eben Waffensperren,
dass also überhaupt gar nichts auf russischem Gebiet stattfinden darf.
Das ist jetzt in zunehmendem Maße aufgeweicht. Die beiden Regierungen sind immer
noch sehr zurückhaltend, was die Verwendung bestimmter Long-Range-Waffen betrifft.
Was mich persönlich immer noch überrascht, dass sie das immer noch durchhalten.
Aber es ist eben auch schon sehr viel jetzt in Bewegung gekommen seitdem.
Ja, oder die USA wollen halt weiter im Wahlkampf nichts anbrennen lassen im Moment.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Teil der Kalkulation, dass das einfach mal jetzt so lange
da die Wahl nicht durch ist.
Also wird Zeit, dass Kamala Harris zur Präsidentin gewählt wird.
Ich glaube erst dann kann man wirklich wieder Fortschritte sehen,
weil sie sich dann halt wieder was trauen können.
Aber wir sollten vielleicht ja noch beim Militärischen bleiben, oder?
Das wollte ich jetzt nur nochmal so zum Abschluss dieser Kursoffensive machen,
dass das eben sozusagen jetzt so die Wirkung von diesem Teil war und ich erwarte
jetzt erstmal in der nächsten Zeit dann nicht so viel Neues.
Kommen wir an den Südrand des Konflikts, was ja so ein Hauptangriffsziel nach wie vor ist,
auch wenn da konkret was die Brücke betrifft nicht so viel passiert.
Das ist halt die Kerchbrücke, also die Straße von Kerch oder die Brücke über
die Straße bei der Stadt Kerch und ja es gab jetzt keine neuen Anschläge auf die Brücke selber,
aber es gab einen sehr erfolgreichen Missileangriff auf die letzte verbliebene Fähre,
Die dort zwischen Russland und der Krim hin und her gefahren ist und die dort
größere Güter rüberbringen konnte. Warum ist das so wichtig?
Wenn es doch die Brücke gibt. Die Brücke ist tatsächlich bei den vergangenen
beiden großen Anschlägen der Ukraine so signifikant zerstört worden oder so
signifikant beschädigt worden,
sagen wir es mal so, dass große,
schwere Tankzüge nicht über die Eisenbahnbrücke mehr gefahren werden konnten.
Also so viel da auch repariert worden ist,
insbesondere eben der Straßenteil, hat der Eisenbahnteil so schwer Schaden genommen,
dass die Spritversorgung mit Eisenbahn, Tankwagen tatsächlich nicht über die Brücke erfolgt ist,
sondern über eine spezielle Eisenbahnfähre.
Also es gab da ein Schiff, die Conro Trader.
Die einfach mehrere Schienen drauf hat. Da fahren dann die Züge direkt auf dieses
Schiff und die fährt dann die ganze Zeit da hin und her.
Ja, auch die Conroe Trader, die gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, weil die ist irgendwie zerstört worden.
Und es gab auch noch zwei andere Fähren, die sind aber schon bei anderen Anschlägen
teilweise beschädigt oder zerstört worden.
Ich glaube, die eine ist gerade in Reparatur, die andere ist auch weg.
Mit anderen Worten, das war es dann mit dem Fährbetrieb an der Kerchbrücke für
die Russen. und deswegen ist halt jetzt derzeit da auch kein Treibstofftransport
mehr mit Waggons möglich.
Was halt noch übrig bleibt sind natürlich Tanklastwagen, das machen sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich, aber das schränkt natürlich im weiteren Maße hier die Logistik
der Russen bei der Versorgung der Krim ein.
Ja, ich habe mich in dem Zusammenhang auch gefragt,
ob die Brücke wirklich mechanisch solche Schäden erlitten hat oder ob man das
nicht auch aus Angst davor macht,
dass die Ukraine eventuell einen
weiteren Zug mit Treibstoffbeladen auf der Brücke einfach angreifen könnte und
dann sozusagen so die Brücke quasi komplett zerstören könnte,
dass man halt einfach das Risiko nicht eingehen möchte.
Unklar, so. Aber eigentlich war ja von den beiden Schienen, die sie dort hatten,
schien ja eigentlich nur eine betroffen zu sein.
Aber gut, das ist zumindest, was du gesagt hast, ist die offizielle Erklärung der Russen.
So, aber ja.
Also es ist keine offizielle Erklärung
der Russen, es ist einfach nur eine Beobachtung, die dort gemacht wurde.
Es gibt da verschiedene Fotos von der Brücke von einem bestimmten Eisenbahnsegment,
was so aussieht, als ob es doch ziemlich schwer Schaden genommen hat von den
Feuern, die dort entstanden sind.
Durch diese erste Sprengung mit dem Lastwagen.
Und ja, das ist halt einfach so.
Auf jeden Fall die Fähre no more und damit auch kein Fährbetrieb eine weitere Einschränkung.
Weitere sehr effiziente Anschläge gab es dann in der Folge auch auf verschiedenen
Militärbasen, insbesondere auch so im südostlichen Bereich,
also hinter der Frontlinie, Volgograd,
der Marinovka Airbase, noch ein paar andere Airbases sind dort beschossen worden.
Und die waren schon extrem effizient, weil man hat dann auf Fotos gesehen,
dass also einiges zerstört wurde.
Und zwar haben die Ukrainer hier offensichtlich auch wieder Waffen eingesetzt,
die sie selber produziert haben. Was das genau war, wissen wir nicht.
Da wurde verschiedenes gemunkelt, aber sie setzen halt auch diese tungsten Wolfram-Munitionen
ein, also wo so viele kleine Kugeln drin sind,
die dann bei der Explosion halt umherschießen und nochmal alles zerfetzen.
Besonders effizient ist das eben gegen Flugzeuge und Hubschrauber,
weil die natürlich mit ihren weichen Blechkleidern, wenn da irgendwo ein Loch
drin ist, dann geht das erstmal gar nicht so. Dann fliegt da einfach gar nichts mehr.
Und damit haben sie diese Militärbasen angegriffen und dabei sind den Russen
dann doch diverse Flugzeuge abhandengekommen sind. Und das sind dann halt meistens
eben diese Bomber, die eben die Gleitbombs werfen.
Von daher ein Primärziel natürlich für die Ukraine, weil von denen wirklich
eine große Gefahr an der Front, aber eben auch eine große Gefahr für die Zivilbevölkerung ausgeht.
Ja, und eine Menge Ground Support Equipment wurde dabei, glaube ich,
auch mit zerstört, was halt auch ein Riesenproblem ist, weil das brauchst du
halt, um die Dinger in der Luft zu halten.
Und das ist teilweise noch schwieriger zu beschaffen.
Parallel dazu gab es auch entsprechende Angriffe mit ähnlicher Technologie auf Tanklager.
Wir hatten ja eine Phase vor ein paar Monaten, wo sie primär so auf die Raffinerien
gegangen sind und dort speziell auf die Technologie der Raffinerien.
Also um die Raffinerien erstmal außer Gefecht zu setzen und das hat ja auch
schon zu einer Reduktion der Produktion geführt.
Jetzt haben sie das nochmal erweitert und sind auf spezielle Tanklager gegangen
und zwar sind das nicht irgendwelche Tanklager, sondern das sind so richtig,
richtig große Reservetanklager.
Also das ist ein riesiges Areal da in Proletarsk, was sie bombardiert haben,
wo ich weiß nicht, 20 riesige Tanks waren mit je 5000 Tonnen Öl und so weiter
und das ist so quasi die Reserve.
Reserve oder anders ausgedrückt, das ist vor allem so der Primärbuffer für ihre Produktion.
Denn Ölproduktion, speziell die in Sibirien, die muss halt die ganze Zeit laufen.
Die kannst du nicht irgendwie einfach mal stoppen, sondern die produziert immer
in einer gewissen Menge und du kannst die nicht einfach mal ausschalten,
weil dann funktionieren die irgendwann nicht mehr.
Mit anderen Worten, du musst dann den Kram auch irgendwo hinbringen.
Und wenn du ihn nicht verkauft bekommst, dann musst du ihn halt irgendwo lagern.
Und wenn du halt keine großen Lager mehr hast, wo du das Öl reinmachst,
dann hast du halt auch ein Problem.
Und diese Angriffe waren super erfolgreich,
vor allem das Ding in Proletarsk, also da haben sie irgendwie 15 Jahre dran
gebaut, dieses Lager aufzubauen und es war danach weitgehend zerstört und es
war bemerkenswert, weil ich glaube es brannte zwei Wochen lang oder sowas.
Also das war einfach irre. Es war nicht zu löschen, es war so viel in Brand
und so eine Hitze, dass sie da, sie haben zwar versucht es irgendwie zu löschen,
aber es ist halt nicht gelungen.
Das Feuer ist immer wieder noch auf andere Bereiche übergegriffen und ich glaube
vor diesem Tanklager ist herzlich wenig übrig geblieben.
Aber es war auch nicht nur das eine, das war nur das Größte.
Es gab dann verschiedene kleinere Tankareale, die glaube ich auch noch angegriffen
wurden und in einem Fall haben sie sogar gleich noch einen zweiten Angriff gemacht,
kaum nachdem es irgendwie gelöscht war, haben sie die restlichen dann auch nochmal abgefackelt.
Also da geht auf jeden Fall ganz schön was ab und es hat sich vor allem dadurch
jetzt schon mal so abgezeichnet, das war ganz schön weit weg und das war ganz schön präzise.
Und womit haben sie denn damit eigentlich angegriffen? Und es hieß halt immer
irgendwie Drohnen, jaja.
Ja, und manchmal hat man ja auch so Videos, wo dann die Drohnenangriffe von
irgendjemandem noch gefilmt werden,
die ein paar Kilometer entfernt sind und dann fliegen die Drohnen an ihnen vorbei
und dann hast du so diese Videos, wo es halt so macht und dann merkst du halt so, okay, alles klar,
das sind jetzt hier klassische Drohnen mit einem normalen Propellermotor,
so wie sie jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit zum Einsatz kommen.
Und jetzt bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz so sicher, ob das jetzt bei Prodetask
auch schon so war, aber es gab dann in zunehmendem Maße weniger solche Videos,
obwohl trotzdem was zerstört wurde und man fragte sich schon so ein bisschen...
Was war denn das jetzt, wenn es hier keine Beobachtung von Drohnenflug gab?
Und was dazu natürlich auch noch kommt ist, diese langsam fliegenden Drohnen
sind natürlich, selbst wenn sie nicht abgeschossen werden, geben sie natürlich
den Russen die Möglichkeit Vorwarnung zu betreiben.
Also speziell bei den Militärbasen war es halt so, dass die dann eben schnell
in die Flugzeuge sind, die Flugzeuge weggeflogen haben und als dann die Drohnen
wirklich auf die Militärbasen runtergegangen sind, mögen sie noch etwas zerstört haben,
aber die Russen waren auch noch in der Lage, relativ viel in Sicherheit zu bringen.
Und bei diesen letzten Anschlägen war das irgendwie auf einmal nicht mehr so.
Da war auf einmal die Zerstörung sehr groß und man wundert sich,
was denn jetzt alles anders war. Werden wir gleich hören.
Vorher noch ein Blick jetzt generell auch auf die neue Militärtechnik mal zwischendurch.
Mittlerweile sind ja die lange versprochenen und angekündigten amerikanischen
F-16-Kampfflugzeuge in der Ukraine eingetroffen, zumindest ein paar.
Wie viele es jetzt genau sind, darüber gibt es sehr unterschiedliche Angaben
oder beziehungsweise erstmal gar keine, aber man geht gemeinhin von so neun oder zehn aus.
Das ist natürlich jetzt noch keine Luftwaffe, mit der man groß arbeiten kann,
weil es ist klar, nur ein Teil von denen kann wirklich in der Luft sein.
Nein, man wird jetzt vor allem diese Maschinen auch erstmal brauchen,
um Bodenpersonal auszubilden und nur ein Teil wird wirklich zum Einsatz gebracht werden können.
Aber dann wurde von Selenskyj auch persönlich und durch ein paar Videos,
dann wurde dann schnell klar gemacht, nein die Dinger sind jetzt nicht nur im
Land, sondern die kommen auch schon zum Einsatz.
Wofür sie dann zum Einsatz kommen?
Wissen wir nicht so ganz genau, aber es macht den Eindruck, dass sie halt,
wie das auch übrigens hier auf UKW vermutet wurde, dass sie halt erstmal Teil
der Raketenabwehr sind.
Dafür eignen sich die F-16 auch und das macht auch Sinn, weil du musst natürlich
jetzt erstmal Erfahrungen sammeln mit diesem Gerät.
Du musst Erfahrungen sammeln beim Bodenpersonal, du musst Erfahrungen sammeln
bei den Piloten, die haben zwar jetzt alle eine Ausbildung hinter sich,
aber wie das so ist, wenn man von der Schule kommt, dann weiß man noch nicht alles.
Und vor allem muss sich halt auch zeigen, wie kriegt die Ukraine diese F-16
in ihr sonstiges Material und in ihre sonstige Logistik das Ganze einfach mit rein.
Weil es hat ja auch alles was mit Warnsystemen zu tun.
Wie notifizierst du die? Wann steigst du jetzt wirklich auf?
Gegen welche Ziele gehst du jetzt mit der F-16 vor? Wie gehst du gegen die anderen vor?
Was ist, wenn jetzt eine F-16 in der Luft ist und versucht Raketen abzuschießen
und deine eigene Luftabwehr detektiert dann die F-16?
Schießt du dann dein eigenes Flugzeug ab? Wie verhinderst du das?
All solche Fragen stehen natürlich
im Raum und insofern ist es auch sehr bedrückend gewesen zu hören,
dass halt relativ bald eine dieser F-16 auch mit einem auch relativ erfahrenen
Piloten abgestürzt ist und dieser Pilot dabei auch ums Leben gekommen ist.
Das war wohl auch so einer ihrer besten Piloten, MIG-Piloten,
der halt auf F-16 umgeschult hat und die Ursache war unklar.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es mittlerweile da andere Informationen gibt.
Ich habe keine weiteren gehört, was denn jetzt wirklich der Grund war.
Das Einzige, was ich als Vermutung gehört habe, war, ja die waren halt in einer
Mission Raketen abzuschießen, haben das dann wohl auch getan,
dann ist aber die Maschine quasi von Debris, also quasi von den zerschossenen
Trümmern getroffen worden und deswegen abgestürzt.
Das kann man glauben oder nicht, das kann auch sein, dass das nicht so war, weiß man nicht.
Ja, nichts Genaues weiß man nicht, aber man hat eine Untersuchung auf jeden
Fall gestartet, wo wohl auch irgendwie die Amerikaner mit hinzugezogen wurden.
Aber ja, offiziell gibt es noch keine Ursache, nur Mutmaßungen.
Ich meine, was wohl ein bisschen der Geschichte Plausibilität gibt,
ist, dass er wohl einige Drohnen oder Cruise Missiles dabei war,
tatsächlich abzuschießen, als es passiert ist.
Und es könnte sich aber auch um einen Friendly-Fire-Incident gehandelt haben.
Ich meine, das ist halt ein gefährlicher Job, Drohnen abzuschießen,
weil natürlich diese Drohnen auch von der eigenen Luftabwehr,
Flugabwehr getrackt werden.
Und ja, das ist dann nicht ganz unproblematisch.
Aber was das jetzt, wie es genau passiert ist, ob es irgendein technisches Versagen
war, eher unwahrscheinlich.
Ob es, wie gesagt, was du gesagt hast, irgendwie einer Cruise Missile zu nahe
gekommen ist und dann von den Trümmern getroffen wurde oder Friendly Fire.
Oder so ein Ausweichmanöver, um nicht getroffen zu werden, dann so ein Low Flight
eingeleitet wurde, der dann wiederum misslungen ist.
Also kann alles mögliche gewesen sein. Spielt auch am Ende keine Rolle.
Tatsache ist, die F-16 sind im Einsatz.
Nicht alles hat von vornherein funktioniert, wie man daran sieht.
Das System muss sich erst noch beweisen.
Ja, aber sie fliegen auch nicht nur zum Training in der Gegend rum,
sondern wie man daran sieht, zerstören sie ja feindliche Cruise Missiles.
Aktuell sind also produktiv in Anführungszeichen im Einsatz,
wenn man die Zerstörung von feindlichen Raketen als produktiv ansehen kann.
Es wurde viel darüber erzählt, dass es generell auch speziell für Piloten,
die vorher eben mit russischer oder sowjetischer Flugtechnik geflogen sind,
ziemlich schwierig ist auf F-16 umgeschült zu werden,
weil dort einfach sehr viele Dinge sehr viel anders funktionieren und bis du
die Automatiken so drin hast.
Ja, aber es ist jetzt ein bisschen müßig darüber zu philosophieren,
ob jetzt da irgendwas hätte verhindert werden können.
Ist ja nicht verhindert worden, von daher läuft es so.
Trotzdem ist die Ukraine bereit, da ins Risiko zu gehen.
Es gibt ja auch das Gerücht, dass Schweden jetzt alte Gripen-Kampfflugzeuge,
die so halb ausgemustert sind,
wieder neu aufbereitet werden, um sie dann der Ukraine zu überstellen.
Wir haben glaube ich über die Gripen schon mal gesprochen.
Mehrfach. Und ich habe aber auch gehört, ganz unabhängig davon,
dass sie auch Leute ausbilden an der Gripen, also Ukrainer.
Im Ground Handling auf jeden Fall und möglicherweise auch als Piloten,
obwohl ich das konkret jetzt nicht bestätigen kann.
Aber vielleicht posaunen sie es auch nicht in die Welt hinaus. aus.
Ja, ich denke auch nicht, dass sie es da besonders eilig damit haben,
so eine Information zu teilen.
Aber irgendwas kommt halt immer wieder durch und ob die Gripen jetzt hier wirklich
zum Einsatz kommt, das in absehbarer Zeit, das werden wir dann sehen.
Wie wir ja schon mal berichtet haben, ist das so rein auf dem Papier ein für
die Ukraine sehr geeignetes Flugzeug.
Ob sie aber in der Lage sind, eben noch diese zusätzliche Logistik und die ganze
Lernphase und das Personal dafür aufzubringen, das wird sich zeigen.
Dann sind vor allem
natürlich die Drohnen das Thema dieses Krieges und gerade in den letzten Wochen
gab es eine ganze Reihe von neuen Videos und damit neuen Erkenntnissen,
was für Arten von Drohnen die Ukraine inne neu einsetzt.
Und da ist einiges Überraschendes dabei.
Das krasseste gleich vorne weg, die sogenannten Dracaris oder auch Drachendrohnen.
Das sind normale Quadrokopter FPV Drohnen.
Also FPV steht ja für First Person View, also wo man quasi eine Videokamera
dran hat und die dann eben Eben so mit einer Brille fliegt, als würde man selber drin sitzen.
Und der Ukraine ist es gelungen, eine Drohne zu bauen, die quasi mit einem Flammenwerfer ausgestattet ist.
Aber der Flammenwerfer ist jetzt nicht so ein Benzin- oder Dieselflammenwerfer,
sondern die Flamme, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das überhaupt so nennen kann,
wird mit Termit durchgeführt.
Termit, wenn ihr es noch nie gehört habt, ist eine Mischung aus...
Das Aluminiumgranulat und Eisenoxid, also Rost.
Und diese Verbindung hat es in sich, denn wenn die entzündet wird,
dann brennt es einfach extrem heiß.
Also wir reden hier von 2400 Grad, sowas in der Größenordnung.
Und Thermit wird zum Beispiel beim Eisenbahnschienenbau eingesetzt,
nur mal so ein Anwendungsbeispiel zu nennen.
Man legt halt die Schienen aus und wenn dann zwei Schienenteile miteinander
verbunden werden sollen,
dann wird da so ein Aufsatz drauf gemacht und dann wird da so Thermit reingegossen,
brennendes Thermit, Was dann halt einfach in sehr kurzer Zeit diesen Bereich
extrem erhitzt und dann verschmelzen diese beiden Schienen und werden wie eins.
Das wird natürlich nochmal nachgeschliffen etc. Aber das ist so eine typische Anwendung für Thermit.
Jetzt haben sie also dieses Material quasi in einen Behälter gepackt,
in irgendeiner Form einen Zündungsmechanismus dazu gebaut
und jetzt fliegen sie mit diesen Drohnen über feindlichen Schützengräben entlang
und lassen sozusagen von oben dieses 2400 Grad heiße Metall in großen Mengen
in diese Gräben reinregnen.
So kann man das glaube ich beschreiben.
Ein unfassbarer Vorgang. Ich habe ein paar Videos gesehen mit dem Ergebnis dieser Operation.
Das war nicht schön. Also ich habe jetzt keine Menschen gesehen,
die da runter gelitten haben, auch wenn es die sicherlich gab.
Aber das ganze Material, was dabei auch schon begossen wurde,
das sah auch nicht mehr feierlich aus.
Ja, also das ist zumindest schon mal eine sehr überraschende und krasse Waffe,
weil es halt auf der einen Seite eben sie in die Lage versetzt quasi die Schützengräben
frei zu räumen und speziell geht natürlich auch Gerät und vor allem Munition, die getroffen wird,
dann sehr schnell in Rauch und Flammen auf.
Ja, es sieht auf jeden Fall sehr spektakulär aus.
Was sie am Boden anrichtet, habe ich jetzt nicht aus der Nähe gesehen.
Aber ja, die Aufnahmen davon sind Hollywood-mäßig.
Ja, absolut. Also Drachendrohnen ist da schon ein sehr angemessener Name.
Ein weiterer Drohnentyp, der von der Ukraine eingesetzt wird,
sind dann Drohnen mit montiertem Maschinengewehr.
Also fliegende Drohnen, wo oben ein Maschinengewehr drauf ist.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt und viele haben sich das wohl auch schon gefragt,
ob das nicht sehr naheliegend ist, sowas mal zu bauen.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das schon mit der einen oder anderen Ingenieursherausforderung
daherkommt, weil so ein Maschinengewehr natürlich extrem viel Rückschlag hat.
Gerade bei dem Video, das da zu sehen war, wo man also die fliegende Drohne,
die Schoss quasi von der Drohne aus selber gesehen hat, da war dann irgendwie
nicht viel von Rückschlagsproblemen zu sehen.
Das hat also dann doch ganz gut funktioniert.
Wie treffgenau das Ganze ist oder mit wie viel Munition die unterwegs sein kann
und wie sinnvoll das dann letzten Endes im Schützengrabenkampf ist, weiß ich nicht.
Aber offensichtlich tut die Ukraine alles dafür, um sozusagen die Menschen da
aus der Frontlinie selber rauszuhalten beim Vorgehen gegen diese feindlichen Linien.
Es gab was ähnliches auch mit montierten Granatwerfern.
Im Prinzip dieselbe Idee. Also man baut jetzt quasi alles auf Drohnen und lässt
die Waffen einfach ferngesteuert durch die Gegend fliegen, anstatt die dann
von Menschen irgendwo hintragen zu lassen.
Ja, spooky.
Ja, das ist in der Tat.
Vor zehn Jahren war es noch Science-Fiction. Vor 15 Jahren habe ich das, glaube ich, gelesen.
So diverse Romane mit dem Thema so bewaffnete Drohnen.
Jetzt nicht mehr ganz so. Was dann auch noch bekannt wurde, sind verschiedene Ground-Drones.
Das hatten wir auch glaube ich schon mal erwähnt, dass es also so ferngesteuerte
Fahrzeuge gibt, die dann teilweise mit einer Begleitflugdrohne unterwegs waren,
vor allem um halt Leute abzutransportieren beziehungsweise um Schützengräben zu versorgen.
Auch da scheint es weitergegangen zu sein. Also das gibt es natürlich nach wie
vor für Transport und Evakuierung etc.
Aber mittlerweile sind halt auch Videos aufgetaucht von solchen kleinen Drohnen
mit montiertem Maschinengewehr.
Also auch hier dasselbe Spiel, bloß eben nicht aus der Luft,
sondern eben vom Boden aus. Das hat ja auch gewisse Vorteile.
Und ja, das scheint auch in zunehmendem Maße ein Ding zu sein.
Auch diese Roboterhunde, die wir ja alle schon kennen, hier von General Dynamics,
glaube ich. Wie heißt die?
General Dynamics?
Ja,
wir wissen alle, was wir meinen.
Also diese Roboterhunde gibt es ja schon eine Weile und das hat sich ja sozusagen
auch schon etabliert, dass die so im Gelände sehr gut unterwegs sind und auch
die werden halt für Aufklärung zum Beispiel benutzt und dann eben aber auch
zum Transport von irgendwelchen Dingen.
Also es ist ein in zunehmendem Maße automatisierter, von Robotik begleiteter
Krieg dort an der Frontlinie.
Ja, und genauso...
Gibt es jetzt auch eine neue Entwicklung im Bereich von Drohnen,
die lange Reichweiten erzielen sollen?
Also wir hatten ja eh schon, Long Range Drohnen ist ja jetzt schon seit einigen Monaten ein Thema.
Es sind Ziele erreicht worden, 1200 Kilometer und weiter von der ukrainischen
Grenze aus oder von der Frontlinie aus.
Aber das waren halt alles diese Propeller-Drohnen, umgebaute Propeller-Flugzeuge etc.
Übrigens, Boston Dynamics war die Firma und General Dynamics baut die F-16.
Ach, okay, gut, dann habe ich das da verdreht. Sehr gut, danke für die Korrektur.
Am Unabhängigkeitstag der Ukraine, das war der 24.
August, gab es dann eine Ankündigung von Präsident Zelensky,
dass die Ukraine eine neue Art von Drohne entwickelt hat,
die sie als Hybrid zwischen Drohne und Missile, also Rakete,
Drohne quasi bezeichnet haben.
Mit anderen Worten, anders als die anderen Drohnen fliegt die nicht mit einem
Propeller durch die Gegend, sondern eben wie eine Rakete mit so einem Raketentriebwerk.
Hat aber auch Eigenschaften einer Drohne.
Was genau jetzt die Eigenschaften sind, die man der Drohne zuschreibt oder der
Missile, darüber kann man jetzt streiten, aber so ist es auf jeden Fall dargestellt worden.
Also, Rakete vielleicht zum Start,
aber die hat ein Jet-Triebwerk, also eine Turbine und keine Rakete wohl,
um auf diese Entfernung zu kommen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Aber es liegt also im Prinzip unter Schall.
Wahrscheinlich eine Geschwindigkeit irgendwas zwischen 500 und 900 Kilometern
pro Stunde dürfte sie fliegen.
Wahrscheinlich die 500 oder so, vielleicht um die Reichweite zu verlängern und
dann so bis zu 900 im Endanflug.
Das wäre mal meine Vermutung.
Und ja und es wird immer von Drohnen gesprochen in dem Zusammenhang, aber ja,
ich habe mich dann gefragt, was unterscheidet das jetzt eigentlich von einer Cruise Missile,
diese Drohne und normalerweise bisher im konventionellen Sprachgebau ist so,
Drohne ist halt ein ferngesteuertes Fluggerät und eine Cruise Missile ist ein.
Autonomes Fluggerät, was halt selbst navigiert und sich selbst steuert.
Jetzt ist es aber nur so, dass diese neuen Drohnen auch Autopiloten an Bord
haben und auch selbstständig ins Ziel fliegen können,
sodass man sich dann fragt, sind es nicht in Wirklichkeit Cruise Missiles,
als von denen hier die Rede ist.
Zumal auch Bruce Missiles wiederum, also Moderne, kann man auch wiederum in
gewissem Maße fernsteuern. Das heißt, das Feature-Set überlappt sich hier quasi.
Und meine Vermutung wäre auch, dass das,
was die Ukraine dort baut, jetzt nicht ganz so sophisticated ist wie jetzt eine
Storm Shadow oder die teuren professionellen Cruise Missiles Taurus,
aber im Grunde genommen Low-Cost Taurus Eigenbau mit höherer Reichweite.
So würde ich das sehen mit vielleicht ein paar Abstrichen, den man rechnen muss,
aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich eher diese Klasse von Waffen.
Und interessant ist, dass ja auch Taurus oder Storm Shadow wird halt immer so
von 300 Kilometern oder bis zu 500 Kilometern Reichweite gesprochen.
Das sind halt Reichweiten, die aufgrund von Verträgen so gemacht wurden.
Und deswegen dürfen die Exportversionen von diesen Cruise Missiles nicht mehr
als 300 Kilometer Reichweite haben und die eigenen nicht mehr als 500 Kilometer Reichweite.
Aber die Ukraine ist natürlich
jetzt solchen Einschränkungen nicht unterworfen und kann deswegen auch diese
Dinge mit einer Reichweite von auch 700 oder 800 oder 1500 Kilometern bauen, wenn sie möchte.
Und was ich vergessen habe,
die sind wohl auch relativ groß und haben wohl auch einen relativ signifikanten
Sprengkopf, also wohl in der Größenordnung von mehreren hundert Kilogramm,
von bis zu 500 ist die Rede.
Aber selbst so 200 oder 300 wären halt schon eine echte Hausnummer.
Das heißt, damit hat die Ukraine so eine bemerkenswerte neue Waffe und auch
in Stückzahlen so aufgelöst.
Die wollte ich eigentlich später bei dem Wirtschaftsteil und bei der russischen Produktion gehen,
aber wir reden hier nicht von ein paar Dutzend, sondern wir reden hier von Hunderten
bis Tausenden dieser Waffen, die die Ukraine produzieren kann.
Und wahrscheinlich eher in so einer Größenordnung von 100 oder mehr pro Monat.
Und es wird vor allem in der Ukraine selber gebaut.
Also man weiß nicht ganz genau, ob sie alle Teile selber auch bauen.
Ich meine, dass dieses Jet-Triebwerk mag vielleicht von woanders kommen.
Es gab ja da mal eine größere Lieferung von etablierten Triebwerkssystemen,
die in vielen Waffen zum Einsatz kommen, von den Kanadiern.
Wo ich mich immer gefragt habe, was wollen sie damit denn machen?
Also das war so in einem Hilfspaket der Kanadier war so eine größere Teilmenge
von so Rocket Engines dabei.
Bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt hier vielleicht zum Einsatz gekommen ist.
Dieser Rocket oder Jet ist ein Riesenuntergang.
Ja, okay. Gut. I don't know. Ich weiß es nicht.
Müsste ich nochmal recherchieren. Auf die Diskussion war ich jetzt nicht vorbereitet.
Ist ja eigentlich auch egal, wo es herkommt. Worauf ich hinaus wollte ist,
im Wesentlichen wird das in der Ukraine gebaut.
Und wie du schon richtig sagst, es gibt halt hier keine politischen Einschränkungen
und dementsprechend ist die einzige Einschränkung, sie müssen es bauen können
und sie müssen es finanzieren können.
Und diese ganze Waffe scheint vor allem auch daraufhin optimiert zu sein,
nicht viel zu kosten im Vergleich zu anderen Cruise Missiles,
die halt eine ganze Menge kosten.
Ja und wie du vorhin richtig auch sagtest,
so mit Geschwindigkeiten von wahrscheinlich diesen 500 bis 900 kmh hast du so
drei bis fünf Sekunden Bekämpfungszeit,
wenn das Ding im Tiefflug auf dich zukommt.
Das heißt, du hörst oder siehst es eben vielleicht in einem...
500 bis 1000 Meter Entfernung, wenn es in 30 Metern Höhe kommt und dann hast
du noch drei Sekunden bis zum Einschlag.
Und das ist also nochmal, wie du richtig sagtest, nochmal auch eine andere Hausnummer,
was die Bekämpfung angeht.
Genau und wenn es halt dann doch in irgendeiner Form wie bei einer Drohne eben
noch die Möglichkeit einer Fernsteuerung gibt und vielleicht einer Spätprogrammierung,
dann hilft es ja auch dabei quasi ein Ziel gegebenenfalls nochmal genauer zu erfassen.
Sagen wir mal, diese Missile nähert sich jetzt sozusagen ihrem Ziel,
liefert dann aber Videodaten zurück, die dann nochmal ausgewertet werden und
dann wird da nochmal so Pinpointing betrieben mit, ja genau möchten wir,
dass du da jetzt reinfliegst.
Kann das Ding ja nochmal im Kreis fliegen und dann vielleicht nochmal genau sein.
Aber ob das der Fall ist, das wissen wir nicht.
Und ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher, ob wir das so bald wissen werden.
Weil außer, dass sie da ein großes Tamtam drum gemacht haben,
dass es das Ding gibt, sind die technischen Details noch überschaubar.
Es gibt noch zwei Aspekte bei dieser Waffe, die ich noch wichtig finde,
gerade im Vergleich jetzt auch zu der Cruise Missile, die du die du erwähnt
hast, also den Taurus und so weiter.
Für Taurus und Storm Shadow brauchst du ein Flugzeug, um die zu starten.
Die kannst du mal nicht im Hinterhof losschießen. Die Pallianitia,
so heißt sie ja, die kann man auf einer normalen Landebahn oder Straße starten.
Die wird auf so ein kleines Wägelchen gesetzt und heizt an, fliegt los,
Wägelchen rollt davon und off it goes. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch schon mal
ein entscheidender Unterschied.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie die Gripen überall starten können als Kampfflugzeuge,
während die F-16 so den Top Tarmac braucht.
Ist das hier auch so ein bisschen so die Hinterhof-Missile. Also die ist in
jederlei Hinsicht an diesen Krieg und an die Bedürfnisse der Ukraine angepasst.
Und das Beste überhaupt daran ist der Name,
weil Palyanitsia, so heißt diese Waffe und die heißt natürlich nicht ohne Grund so.
Was ist das? Palyanitsia ist ein Brot.
Ein klassisches ukrainisches Weißbrot, Weizenweißbrot,
was man in der Ukraine halt gerne isst und was da irgendwie herkommt und so
ein typisches ukrainisches Brot, so ein Lebensmittel ist.
Und warum heißt jetzt eine Waffe Brot?
Weil dieses Wort Paljanitsia, das ist mit Lauten angereichert,
die es in der ukrainischen Sprache gibt, aber nicht im russischen.
Mit anderen Worten, Russen haben Schwierigkeiten, dieses Wort auszusprechen.
Wenn Russen da nicht besonders für geübt haben, weil diesen Zia-Sound haben sie nicht drin.
Und es gibt viele Geschichten, ich hab mir das auch nochmal,
als ich in der Ukraine war, hab ich die Story auch noch ein paar mal erzählt
bekommen, also it's true.
Als es halt gerade zu Beginn des Krieges so eine Sache war mit,
sind hier Russen unter uns und sind wir gerade irgendwie infiltriert worden,
als sie Straßensperren aufgebaut haben etc.
Um sich vor Infiltrationen zu schützen, haben sie halt die Leute Paljanitsja sagen lassen.
Und damit haben sie halt Russen rausgefiltert, die dann halt dieses Wort nicht
richtig sagen konnten und sich dadurch verraten haben, dass sie Russen waren.
Also das ist sozusagen die Backstory und das ist der besondere Witz quasi jetzt bei dieser Benennung.
Also das ist quasi dieses Brot ist durch seinen Namen und durch die Verwendung
dieses Namens in der Ukraine halt auch zu so einem Symbol,
einem weiteren Symbol des Widerstands gegen Russland angewachsen.
Um nochmal, aber sozusagen die Konfusion jetzt zwischen Rakete und Jet vielleicht
nochmal aufzuklären, ist,
dass das Ding mit Hilfe von Raketentriebwerken startet, also beschleunigt wird.
Das heißt wahrscheinlich auf dem Wagen sind Raketentriebwerke montiert.
Aber die eigentliche Strecke macht es halt mit einem Jet-Triebwerk, mit einer Turbine.
Die dann Kerosin verbrennt, während Raketen halt,
naja, direkt einfach Schub erzeugen durch Verbrennung von Raketentreibstoff,
der dann hinten einfach rausgeschickt wird.
Und ja, Turbinen drehen halt eine Turbine, die dann selber dann auch noch Luft
nach vorne schiebt und Abgase hinten rauspumpt.
Und aber wesentlich dadurch kommen die halt auf die Strecken,
weil wenn es jetzt Raketen getrieben wäre,
könnte die nicht 500 oder 700 Kilometer weit fliegen, sondern dann müsste es
eine ballistische Rakete sein, die dann irgendwie schnell nach oben geht und
dann durchs Weltall fliegt.
Gut, so hätten wir das auch geklärt. So, und dass diese Pallianitia,
dass die zum Einsatz kommt, Das wissen wir jetzt auch.
Oder zumindest gibt es starke Hinweise darauf.
Denn wie schon zu Beginn angekündigt, es gab jetzt Angriffe auf russische Munitionsdepots.
Und zwar ist das ja an sich jetzt erstmal nichts Neues,
so Munitionslager werden am laufenden Meter überall angegriffen,
in Städten irgendwo liegen welche rum und dann natürlich in den Schützengräben
und wenn du halt irgendwo Krieg betreiben willst mit Waffen,
dann brauchst du halt auch die Munition.
In anderen Worten, Munitionslager sind überall und man muss sie halt nur finden
und wenn man da was draufwirft, ist es natürlich immer besonders cool,
weil man eben mit einem Schuss quasi sehr viel Munition zerstört.
Was sie aber jetzt angegriffen haben sind nicht irgendwelche Munitionsdepots,
sondern das sind so die größten und am besten gesicherten Munitionsdepots Russlands,
derer es zumindest westlich des Urals gar nicht mal so viele zu geben scheint.
Wenn ich hier nicht falsch informiert bin, gibt es derer gerade mal so, naja, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Und das sind riesige Areale, die teilweise mehrere Kilometer lang sind.
Also das erste, von dem wir gleich sprechen werden in Toropetz,
das ist das größte, glaube ich, gewesen von allen oder ist das größte von allen.
Das ist tatsächlich fünf Kilometer lang. Also über 5 Kilometer muss man sich
vorstellen, ein riesiges Areal, wo dann mit einem gewissen Sicherheitsabstand
ein Munitionslager neben dem nächsten ist,
also große Hallen, wo Munition drin lagert.
Und dann im Falle der Größeren dieser Lager, speziell in Toropetz,
gibt es dann auch nochmal Munitionslagerbereiche, die speziell gesichert sind
mit Bunkerstrukturen darüber.
Und es wird im Allgemeinen davon ausgegangen, dass unter diesen Bunkerstrukturen
eben die besonders wertvollen Raketen gelagert werden.
Also das sind vor allem diese Iskander-Raketen oder eben vergleichbare Langstrecken-Raketen
aus Nordkorea oder was auch immer.
Das sind also wirklich massive Installationen in der Landschaft,
so groß wie eine ganze Ortschaft und die haben die Ukrainer jetzt ins Visier gefasst.
Also allein in Toropetz habe ich gehört, sollen rund 10% der russischen Munitionsvorräte
insgesamt gelagert haben.
Also 10% von allem, was Russland hat. Tatsächlich.
Also ich habe nur eine Zahl, eine absolute Zahl gehört,
die so auf 40.000 Tonnen Munition kam und 40.000 Tonnen Munition entsprach auch
in etwa der Einschätzung,
was Russland in dem Krieg gegen die Ukraine derzeit binnen eines Monats verbraucht.
Ja, also es gab auch, andere haben geschätzt, dass das so zwei bis drei Monaten Verbrauch entspricht.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich schwierig, da ist jetzt vorher keiner durchgegangen
und hat das genau gezählt, was da drin war.
Es gibt sekundäre Hinweise darauf.
Dass da einiges war.
Ich sag mal, wenn du sagst, dass es jetzt sieben große Depots gibt und Toropetz das größte war.
Also westlich des Urals, wohlgemerkt. Also mehr oder weniger so im Einzugsgebiet
noch ukrainischer Drohnenstrecken.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall.
Kann schon hinhauen, dass das 10 Prozent sind. Also gerade weil das eben so
super groß ist und die anderen sind eben nicht alle super groß und vor allem
die wenigsten haben auch noch diese speziellen Bunkerabsicherungen,
die jetzt in Toropetz dort waren.
Also Bunker heißt in diesem Fall, das ist halt auch nochmal ein Areal,
also allein diese Bunkerdinger, das sind sowieso an die 25 Bunker ausgestreckt auch über so eine,
also ich glaube allein dieser Bunkerbereich ist genau zwei Kilometer breit.
Also zwei Kilometer mal ungefähr ein Kilometer, wo dann eben so 25 dicke Bunker
sind, unter denen dann vermutlich eben größere Mengen an Raketen gelagert sind.
Also unfassbare Dimensionen.
Manche der angegriffenen Munitionslager sind auch gerade noch im letzten Jahr
auch nochmal ausgebaut worden.
Also teilweise sind sie noch etwas größer, als man sie jetzt auf Google Earth so finden kann.
Ja, und was insbesondere auch zerstört wurde,
waren teure Raketen, also ballistische Raketen und Flugabwehrraketen, so S-300,
eine ganze Menge.
Und weil das konnte man deswegen sagen,
weil dort zu der Zeit fünf Züge sich auch auf dem Gelände befanden dieses Munitionslagers
und dabei waren gerade Munition ein- oder auszuladen.
Und es Satellitenbilder vom Vortag gibt, wo man sehr schön die Raketen neben
der Eisenbahn sehen kann, wie sie dort gelagert sind.
Und auf den Danachbildern sind noch eine Handvoll davon übrig geblieben und der Rest ist weg.
Und genauso haben alle fünf Züge in unterschiedlichem Maße Schaden genommen.
Ich meine, diese Züge sind ja dann auch teilweise Kilometer lang.
Deswegen ist da dann oft nur in der Mitte so ein paar hundert Meter rausgesprengt
oder so und das Anfang und Ende sind noch da.
Bei anderen Zügen hat es sogar komplett die Lokomotive zerstört Dort und auf
den Luftbildern sind es zu sehen,
was mich und dann auch den Kommentator, der in dem Video das kommentiert hat,
als Tunguska ähnliche Strukturen bezeichnet worden.
Das heißt, dort befand sich halt in der Mitte ein Krater und rund um den Krater war mal Wald.
Und alle Bäume sind aber weggeknickt, quasi auf dem Boden liegen zu sehen und
zeigen eben alle weg von diesem Krater.
Und da stand vorher ein Bunker.
Und was immer in diesem Bunker war, war auf jeden Fall hochexplosiv.
So, bei den Raketen konnte man dann sagen,
weil dort waren die Explosionen nicht so hoch,
dass man davon ausgeht, dass es sich wahrscheinlich überwiegend eben um Luftabwehrraketen
handelt, die eine relativ kleine Menge jetzt an Sprengstoffen tatsächlich,
also mit kleinen Sprengköpfen.
Aber in anderen Bereichen eben waren definitiv auch ziemliche Kracher zu sehen.
Und ja, es wurden auch dann die Explosionen von Seismometern rund um die Welt so aufgenommen.
Also es war wohl Explosionen im Kilotonnenbereich, die dort stattgefunden haben.
Also ich glaube es war so 2,3 oder 2,5 auf der Richterskala,
was diese Explosion ausgelöst hat.
Also kein Erdbeben, von dem jetzt Häuser umfallen, aber was man definitiv spüren
kann und auf jeden Fall gut messen kann.
Ja, also man muss auch sagen, wenn wir vielleicht erstmal bei diesem großen
Munitionslager Toropetz bleiben weiter als Beispiel.
Beispiel, also ungefähr das, was ich vorhin beschrieben habe,
diese Bunkerstrecke mit den ganz großen Raketen von diesen, was habe ich gesagt,
25, ich glaube es gibt so 40, ich weiß nicht ganz genau,
davon sind also die meisten auch wirklich zerstört worden, das lässt sich ganz gut sehen.
Von allen anderen Strukturen die im Wesentlichen so Hallencharakter haben,
ist nahezu alles zerstört worden, also es ist irgendwie irgendwo eine Halle glaube ich,
übrig geblieben es ist wirklich krass, auch alle außen liegenden Munitionsmengen
also man sieht das zumindest auf alten Google Maps Bildern, ob dann genau an
dem Tag auch da noch so viel rumstand das wissen wir natürlich nicht,
aber wenn man halt mal drauf schaut, wie viel da auf Ja und?
Rumliegt, dann kann ich mir kaum vorstellen, dass es da groß anders ausgesehen haben wird.
Es ist einfach alles platt. Es ist einfach komplett überhaupt nichts übrig geblieben.
Alles ist zerstört und was das uns sagt, ist,
Hier ist nicht eine Rakete eingeschlagen und dann ist zufällig von Haus zu Haus
der Feuerteufel rübergesprungen, sondern dieses Munitionslager wurde großflächig von einer sehr,
sehr, sehr großen Zahl von extrem präzisen Raketen angegriffen,
weil alles sieht nach Volltreffer aus. Das ist wirklich krass.
Ja, das ist nämlich das Ding, was ich mich zuerst gefragt habe.
Sind die Russen eigentlich so inkompetent, dass wenn da zufällig,
wie sie selber behaupten, die Trümmer einer abgeschossenen Drohne drauf fallen,
weil das dann irgendwie 20 oder 30 Quadratkilometer an Lager explodieren.
Nee, ganz so inkompetent sind sie nicht. Sie haben zwar eine ganze Menge Zeugs
zu lange einfach rechts und links neben den Gleisen gelagert,
Aber der Großteil war halt schon eigentlich getrennt voneinander untergebracht.
Aber es wurden Zahlen genannt, zum Beispiel von Zeihan,
der davon ausging, dass ungefähr 100 von diesen Drohnen auf das Lager abgeschossen
wurden und der Großteil davon auch getroffen.
Das heißt, das waren nicht ein,
zwei verwirrte Raketen, die da eingeschlagen sind, sondern die haben im Prinzip
wahrscheinlich zwei auf jeden Bunker programmiert.
Und bei den meisten ist auch mindestens eine durchgekommen.
So würde ich das sehen, was da passiert ist.
Und dass so viel nebenbei noch drumherum lag und in den Zügen und so,
das hat die Situation jetzt nicht gerade besser gemacht.
Also man weiß es nicht, aber es gibt die Vermutung, dass eben die von uns eben
gerade beschriebene Pallianitia-Rakete, Missile, Drohne, was auch immer, hier ...
Also es kann gut sein, dass das sozusagen jetzt die erste große Anwendung war
dieses Waffensystems und wenn dem so ist, dann haben die Russen ein echtes Problem.
Weil wenn sie jetzt schon dieses Munitionslager, was, ich messe nochmal kurz nach,
einen Abstand zur ukrainischen Grenze und damit eben auch den Frontverlauf hat von Trommelwirbel,
kürzestes Wege, 500 Kilometer.
Ja, es ist so 600 Kilometer nördlich von Kiew, aber nur 250 Kilometer östlich
von Lettland, von der Grenze.
Und nur 200 Kilometer nordöstlich von Moskau.
So, also es ist 400 Kilometer.
Von Oskar entfernt. 400? Ja.
Ja, ich messe das hier gerade nach, also von daher kannst du beglauben.
Aber wie gesagt, bis zur Ukraine 500 Kilometer Abstand auf jeden Fall.
Mit anderen Worten, es passt in diese Beschreibung.
In großer Zahl vorhanden, keine Auflagen der Amerikaner, fliegt präzise und
schnell genug, dass die Russen nichts dagegen tun können.
Neue Entwicklung der Ukraine, die irgendwie alles draufgesetzt hat,
dass das irgendwie gut funktioniert.
Und ja, sie sind in der Lage, große Sprengköpfe und mit 100 Stück auf einmal
angeflogen kommen und es macht Bäm.
Also das passt schon. Man wüsste jetzt nicht so richtig, was es sonst hätte
sein sollen, weil es waren mit Sicherheit keine normalen Propellerdrohnen und
es waren auch mit Sicherheit keine umgebauten Neptun-Missiles,
weil davon haben sie nicht so viele.
Und von daher glaube ich.
Kann sich hier schon ein, jetzt hätte ich fast Game Changer gesagt,
also ein Waffensystem kündigt sich hier an, was den Russen nochmal sehr viel Schmerzen bereitet.
Zumal, dieser Angriff auf das große Toropetz-Munitionslager nicht alleine daherkam,
sondern zwei, drei Tage später.
Traf es dann gleich noch ein zweites kleineres Munitionslager,
was von dem anderen in Toropetz tatsächlich nicht weit entfernt ist.
Die trennen nämlich nur, wie weit ist das entfernt?
Und na, das sind gerade mal 15 Kilometer Luftlinie.
Und dort gibt es nämlich noch ein weiteres Areal, was zwar nicht mit diesen
Hardcore-Bunkern, aber eben mit diesen anderen Lagerhallen versorgt ist.
Und auch das hat so ungefähr, naja, so drei Quadratkilometer Fläche.
Und auch davon ist genau gar nichts übrig geblieben.
Also es ist wirklich alles komplett vollständig zerstört worden.
Das sind auch irgendwie so an die 30 verschiedene Hallen, die ich jetzt hier
mal so grob überschlage, die ich hier sehe und Züge waren da wahrscheinlich
auch und damit auch nicht genug,
sondern es gab auch noch ein drittes Munitionslager dieser Größenordnung,
das lag dann in der Ortschaft Tikhoretsk, das ist in Krasnodar,
das ist quasi östlich vom Asowschen Meer.
Auch signifikant weit von der ukrainischen Grenze entfernt, wenn auch nicht
ganz so weit, also von der Frontlinie ungefähr so 400 Kilometer kann man sagen, 350,
400 Kilometer und auch dieses Lager hat es weitgehend zerlegt.
Ja, also die beiden Lager im Gebiet Tver gehörten übrigens beide zur Hauptverwaltung
für Raketen und Artillerie,
die GRAU.
Das eine, das große bei Toropetz war irgendwie das 107.
Arsenal bzw.
Munitionsdepot der Hauptverwaltung und das andere war das 23.
Arsenal der Hauptverwaltung. Das heißt, das sind nicht irgendwelche jetzt kleinen
Truppen, sondern das ist die Hauptverwaltung.
Das sind die Arsenale der Hauptverwaltung, die dort angegriffen wurden.
Und wo eben auch,
wie der Name schon sagt, Raketen und Artillerie lagern und während da in der
Nähe von Tichoretz bei Krasnodar,
das war wiederum eine reine Artillerie-Munitionsbasis, was auch immer das sein
mag, also vermutlich ein bisschen kleiner.
Ja genau, also artillerische Munition liegt wahrscheinlich in Russland überall rum.
Das ist das ganz normale 152 Millimeter Geschoss, was die Russen ja in Unmengen verwenden.
Und ja, das dürfte wahrscheinlich in jedem Munitionslager nicht fehlen.
Und das ist dann eben in diesen normalen Lagerhallen. Aber die dicken fetten
Raketen, die liegen jetzt nicht überall rum.
Insofern kann es durchaus sein, auch wenn sich das natürlich jetzt nicht beweisen
lässt, aber es kann durchaus sein, dass die Russen jetzt im Raketenbereich ein
Versorgungsproblem haben.
Und von daher konnte natürlich dieser Schlag nicht früh genug kommen,
weil natürlich jetzt alle wieder Angst haben, dass mit den großen Raketen die
Russen wieder versuchen werden, die Energieinfrastruktur der Ukraine zu zerstören im Winter.
Ja, achso. Ein anderes Problem noch.
Es wurde nicht nur eben Munition und Lagerkapazität für Munition zerstört.
Also dieses Lager hat wohl Milliarden an Dollars gekostet, das zu bauen.
Das war also auch nicht billig, aber es war eben auch nicht nur ein reines Lager,
sondern dort wurde eben auch viel Munition reaktiviert, also Einrichtungen und
Experten, um ältere Munition wieder nutzbar zu machen.
Und insbesondere sollen die wohl die Munition aus Nordkorea dort in Empfang
genommen und überarbeitet bzw.
Qualitätskontrolliert haben. Und diese Einrichtungen sind natürlich jetzt auch weg.
Und es wurde wohl auch ein signifikanter Teil eben der nordkoreanischen Munition genutzt.
Dort zerstört, also ich glaube 300 von 1000 gelieferten Containern aus Nordkorea
standen wohl auf dem Gelände, um eben dort überarbeitet zu werden.
Und ja, diese Überarbeitungskapazität ist dann auch jetzt deutlich reduziert worden.
Und die Frage ist, wo es überhaupt noch Einrichtungen gibt, die logistisch so
angebunden sind und die notwendigen Vorrichtungen haben, um Munition zu überarbeiten.
Und selbst wenn, ist auch die Frage, wie viel des Personals bei diesem Angriff
jetzt auch noch hops gegangen ist.
Ja, nach offiziellen russischen Meldungen soll es nur elf Tote gegeben haben dabei.
Das ist ja eine geile Quelle. Das sind dieselben Leute, die vor diesem brennenden
Munitionslager standen und während hinten alles noch explodierte,
die Kamera reindiktierten, dass das ja nur heruntergefallene Trümmer von einer
abgeschossenen Drohne sind, die da jetzt gerade ein Feuer ausgelöst haben.
Wäre jetzt nicht auszuschließen, dass sie dort rund um die Uhr in drei Schichten gearbeitet haben.
Das wäre natürlich tragisch, aber darauf deutet, darüber gibt es zumindest keine
Informationen, dass es jetzt mehr gewesen wären.
Auch die Ukraine behauptet nicht, dort, glaube ich, mehr Leute getötet zu haben.
Und es war halt in der Nacht.
Also es gibt eine gute Chance auch, dass eben dort nachts eben nicht so viel gearbeitet wurde.
Okay, das wusste ich jetzt gar nicht, wann die Angriffe waren,
aber okay, nachts. Naja.
So viel Daten, oder? Haben wir alles erzählt?
Man kann sagen, das tat auf jeden Fall richtig weh und wird mittelfristig auch
Auswirkungen auf die Front haben,
eventuell sogar kurzfristig, weil da erstmal eine Menge Nachschub zwar jetzt
nicht direkt im Moment die Front betrifft,
so der verloren gegangen ist,
aber die wissen halt jetzt an der Front oder die kleineren Lager in der Kette
wissen jetzt, dass da erstmal eine Weile nichts nachkommt.
Das heißt, dass sie möglicherweise jetzt schon präventiv sagen,
wir müssen jetzt unsere Vorräte strecken und dass das deswegen Deswegen, ja,
jetzt früher die gespart werden muss einfach an Munition an der Front,
auch wenn eigentlich noch genug da ist.
Aber ja, das, weil man halt jetzt erstmal auch einen Engpass erwartet mit Sicherheit
in bestimmten Regionen.
Und es war teuer.
Also man geht davon aus, dass Munition mindestens im Wert von 300 Millionen
Dollar, Aber es könnte auch sich um Milliarden handeln. Niemand weiß es so genau.
Aber die Raketen sind, gerade die Raketen gehen halt ganz schön ins Geld.
Und ja, das tat weh und wird spürbar sein an der Front.
Hoffen wir es. Gut kommen wir mal ein bisschen weg von,
dem Militärischen und schauen mal ein paar andere Aspekte noch an, was,
wobei ich nicht so richtig viel zu sagen kann tatsächlich aber was auf jeden
Fall erwähnenswert ist noch nebenbei, es gab innerhalb der ukrainischen Regierung,
wieder einiges an Bewegung und das ist auch gar nichts äh neues.
Zelensky hat jetzt schon mehrfach so ein Reshuffling seines Kabinetts vorgenommen
und jetzt ist glaube ich auch das zweite Mal so der Verteidigungsminister gewechselt,
ein Außenminister und so weiter.
Das heißt, es werden eigentlich immer wieder mal die Leute aus wichtigen Positionen
rausgenommen und woanders befördert. Die werden aber nicht ähm.
Oder bestraft oder so für irgendetwas. Das gab es auch. Es gab ja auch Korruptionsfälle,
wo Leute abgesetzt worden sind.
Aber das sind eher so Rotationen, kann man fast sagen.
Und das hat relativ wenig Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt, woraus ich so rauslese,
dass das eben auch schon in gewisser Hinsicht normal ist.
Weil manche sind dann halt einfach,
also wir hatten das ja mit General Saluschny, dem Chef der Streitkräfte,
der ja dann jetzt durch den aktuellen Surski ersetzt wurde, der ist aber nicht
irgendwie gefeuert worden, sondern wurde abgelöst und ist mittlerweile Botschafter in Großbritannien.
Auch andere Mitglieder des Kabinetts, kriegst du jetzt gerade nicht so aufgezählt,
sind teilweise eben in diplomatischen Dienst gegangen,
also haben dann angefangen international für die Ukraine zu arbeiten und so
bewegt er diesen ganzen Regierungsapparat immer wieder neu.
Und das könnte zwei Gründe haben.
Es könnte auf der einen Seite den Grund haben, dass er dadurch natürlich so
einer gewissen Korruptionsgefahr auch vorbeugt, weil wenn jemand nicht jetzt
jahrelang in einer Ministerrolle drin ist,
dann kann man sich da eben nicht so festsetzen und Strukturen können sich nicht verfestigen.
Aber ich glaube, es könnte auch so ein bisschen sein, dass er eben auch die
Leute frisch halten will.
Dass sozusagen immer wieder neue Leute auch eine Chance bekommen und ihre neuen Ideen einbringen.
Sodass sie quasi nicht festhängen in irgendeinem Kriegstrott,
aus dem sie dann sozusagen nur im Albtraum wieder aufwachen,
weil sie festgestellt haben, dass sie nicht mehr schnell genug auf Dinge reagiert haben.
Finde ich auf jeden Fall ganz interessant, weil man das ja normalerweise so
nicht sieht im politischen Geschäft.
Ja, gut, ist so bisher so meiner Aufmerksamkeit entgangen.
Aber ja, das Problem ist natürlich in der Ukraine, dass unter den Bedingungen
jetzt keine Wahlen wirklich stattfinden können.
Also auf nationaler Ebene jedenfalls nicht, weil...
Viele Leute nicht mitwählen könnten im Moment und auch die Bedingungen für einen
Wahlkampf gerade nicht wirklich gegeben sind,
was natürlich nicht ganz unkritisch ist.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man wahrscheinlich auch davon ausgehen,
dass Selenskyj haushoch gewinnen dürfte, wenn jetzt eine Präsidentschaftswahl stattfinden würde.
Aber es wären eben auch keine fairen demokratischen Wahlen, die man veranstalten würde.
Das ist so das Problem. Aber das kann natürlich auch nicht ewig so weitergehen
und unter den Bedingungen macht es möglicherweise auch Sinn,
dass dort eben Austausch stattfindet, auch ohne Neuwahlen.
Das könnte vielleicht auch noch ein Aspekt sein.
Ja, also der Ministerpräsident ist nach wie vor dieser Dennis Schmierhal,
der ist seit März 20 im Geschäft,
aber ich meine im Bereich der Verteidigung und Außenminister gab es verschiedene Bewegungen.
Also der Dimitro Kuleba war jetzt bis zum 5.
September und der ist jetzt durch jemand anders ersetzt worden.
Auf jeden Fall gab es verschiedene Bewegungen in den Ministerien.
Also hier Fragen strategischer Infrastruktur.
Achso, das ist vielleicht noch ganz interessant, dieser Oleksandr Kamyschin.
Also es gibt ein Ministerium für Fragen strategischer Infrastruktur.
Das gibt es seit Juli 20 und das kannst du dir schon vorstellen,
was für eine strategische Infrastruktur das ist.
Also da geht es um den Militär-Innovationsbereich. Reich.
Das war jetzt bis zum 4. September war der Minister halt Oleksandr Kamyschin,
den hast du bestimmt schon mal gesehen,
der ist halt ein sehr auffälliger Typ, allein schon, weil er eben so eine typisch ukrainische,
Kosakenfrisur auch trägt und das war derjenige, der zunächst einmal von Zelensky
eingesetzt wurde, um die Eisenbahn wieder auf Vollermann zu bringen,
das ja hervorragend funktioniert hat.
Dann ist er im März 1923 ist er dann eben Minister für strategische Infrastruktur
und jetzt ist er weitergeleitet worden in neue Aufgaben,
von denen nicht genau gesagt wurde, was es ist.
Also das scheint mir so ein besonderer Spezi zu sein von Selensky,
der sich schon sehr bewährt hat und der eine Menge auf die Reihe bekommen hat.
Also soweit ich weiß, war zum Beispiel dieser ganze Aufbau der Drohnenarmee
quasi jetzt vor allem sein Werk,
weil er es geschafft hat, die Wirtschaft entsprechend zusammenzubringen,
um diesen Innovationsdruck dort zu erzeugen.
Aber es sind auch viele andere Posten, also Verteidigungsminister ist ausgetauscht
worden, Sportminister ist ausgetauscht worden,
Minister für Veteranenangelegenheiten ist ausgetauscht worden,
also passiert einiges, Gemeindeentwicklung, Territorien, also einmal so ein
Reschaffel, nichts ist genauso, Justizministerium ist ausgetauscht worden.
Findet statt. Gut, dann gucken wir mal ein bisschen auf die internationale Politik.
Da dreht sich natürlich vor allem viel um die USA und um die ganze Diskussion
der Erlaubnis einer weiteren Strategie.
Also derzeit ist Zelensky unterwegs in den USA und präsentiert,
wie es so schön heißt in den Medien, seinen Victory Plan.
Wie du vorhin schon richtig gesagt hast, die Amerikaner halten sich sehr zurück,
was irgendwelche Entscheidungen betrifft und belassen erstmal alles beim Alten.
Ich glaube, das ist im Wesentlichen eine Entscheidung von Biden selbst und seinem Sicherheitsberater.
Man will irgendwie nicht diesen Schritt gehen und sagen, nehmt doch,
was ihr habt und nehmt doch alles, was ihr von uns kriegen könnt und macht damit, was ihr wollt.
Zu diesem Schritt ist die USA derzeit einfach nicht bereit, obwohl der Widerstand
aus Europa relativ stark ist.
Vielleicht mit Ausnahme von Olaf Scholz, der halt der Einzige ist,
der dieselbe Linie fährt, warum auch immer.
Ja, das ist so das, was eigentlich die internationale Situation im Wesentlichen dominiert.
Die Debatte in Deutschland, gerade dabei sind,
ist dabei auch nicht besonders berühmlich gerade,
weil man versucht jetzt so ein bisschen knauserig zu werden und versucht jetzt quasi,
ja, äh,
Eigentlich eigene Finanzhilfen runterzufahren tatsächlich,
aber das nicht so zu nennen,
sondern eben Gelder, die die Ukraine selbst erwirtschaftet,
beziehungsweise Gelder, die aus den Zinsen von den russischen eingefrorenen Anlagen stammen,
die ja jetzt in die Ukraine fließen,
will man quasi dann die eigenen Hilfen entsprechend reduzieren,
weil ja jetzt Geld von anderswo kommt.
Und aber so tun, als wäre das auch Geld, was man selber bereitstellt.
Also man zahlt sich sozusagen die Zinsen des russischen Geldes selber aus.
Ja, so genau. Im Vergleich zum Status Quo.
So, das ist der deutsche Plan im Moment, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe.
Ja, das ist einfach nur schändlich.
So, das ist ja wieder nichts Ganzes und nichts Halbes und versucht sich aus
der Affäre zu ziehen irgendwie und ja.
Ja, ist traurig.
Ja, kommt auch noch, das war ja, und dann sucht man so zu tun,
als, ja,
würden wir dort sparen. Aber wir, ich meine, zur Wirtschaft in der Ukraine, zur Situation,
kommen wir noch, aber muss halt auch festhalten, noch in dem Zusammenhang,
weil Trump behauptet, die USA würden ja viel mehr zahlen und Europa würde irgendwie
nicht seinen Teil dazu beitragen.
Was die Ukraine angeht, ist es so, dass aus den USA zwar die meisten Waffen kommen,
aber in Geld gemessen stellt Europa irgendwie 60 Prozent mehr zur Verfügung als die USA.
Und Deutschland ist halt ein signifikanter Teil von Europa, ein signifikanter Teil davon.
Und die USA liefern halt vor allem auch sehr viele Waffen, die sie sowieso verschrotten
müssten. Also nicht nur, aber auch.
Ja, ja, aber die werden dann entsprechend auch, ich sag mal,
nicht zum Anschaffungspreis auch bewertet in den Hilfspaketen,
Sondern teilweise wird nur der Transport dann in Rechnung gestellt,
der aber wahrscheinlich den Wert der Waffen oft übersteigt.
Es ist in vielen Fällen teurer, die Sachen zu transportieren,
als das, was sie wert sind.
Ja, also andere, also es gibt natürlich sehr viel auf diesem internationalen
Parkett, was passiert in Bezug auf die Ukraine und jedes Land hat dann natürlich
seine eigene Position. Opposition.
Generell habe ich so den Eindruck, Europa teilt sich so in, ich sag mal in, grob in vier Teile.
Da ist so Deutschland.
Also ein Teil. Dann gibt es noch den richtig unproduktiven Teil wie die Slowakei
und Ungarn, also die eher so einen pro-russischen Eindruck machen.
Okay, das sind vielleicht fünf Teile. Dann haben wir so den Westen,
der im Wesentlichen sich, der stark unterstützt.
Das ist dann halt sowas wie Holland und dann ab geschwächter Form dann so eben
Spanien, Frankreich, die alle irgendwie so ein bisschen was tun.
Und so als fünfte Gruppe würde ich dann vor allem nochmal Osteuropa,
also inklusive Polen und Skandinavien und das Baltikum nennen,
die halt sagen wir mal den progressiven Teil darstellen.
Progressiv insofern, als dass sie eben wirklich Druck machen,
dass sie eine klare Positionierung haben gegenüber Russland,
eine klare Positionierung haben gegenüber der Ukraine. Die Realisten.
Ich würde auch sagen, die Realisten. Ja, also der Petre Pavel,
der tschechische Präsident,
der hat ja auch gesagt, wir können die Ukraine sogar in die NATO aufnehmen,
selbst wenn noch Bereiche besetzt sind.
Also die drehen eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit so die Grenze der Debatte immer wieder neu auf.
Ja, das machen die teilweise die baltischen Länder auch,
wobei sie gut einerseits natürlich massiv betroffen sind,
andererseits aber auch, wenn es so um Forderungen geht,
wie NATO-Truppen in die Ukraine zu entsenden, dass dann auch mehr gebellt ist an der Stelle,
weil es nicht realistisch ist,
und sie auch eigentlich nicht viel haben, was sie setzen können in nennenswerter Menge.
Also die haben teilweise, wenn ich die baltischen Staaten zwischen.
10.000 und 30.000 aktive Soldaten überhaupt,
ja insgesamt im ganzen Land und insofern, aber es ist natürlich schon wichtig,
dass irgendjemand auch das Fenster des Gesagten oder Sagbaren etwas weiter aufspannt.
Wer allerdings richtig signifikant Nägel mit Köpfen macht, ist natürlich Polen,
die sich ganz konkret auf einen Krieg mit Russland vorbereiten.
So anders kann man das nicht nennen. Also die Polen gehen davon aus,
dass die Russen kommen werden.
Beziehungsweise wenn sie nicht wollen, dass die Russen kommen,
dass sie ein Militär brauchen, das so stark ist, dass die Russen sich einfach nicht trauen zu kommen.
Ja, das ist ganz klar.
Polen wissen, wenn sie das nicht machen, dann kommen die Russen.
Und ja, das ist halt diese perverse Logik der Abschreckung, dass,
ja, wenn du eben so einen Nachbarn hast, der imperiale Ambitionen hat und nicht
davor zurückschreckt, in Nachbarländer einzumarschieren und das immer wieder getan hat.
Ja, dann ist es eigentlich sehr klug, davon auszugehen, dass wenn du nicht hinreichend
vorbereitet bist, dass sie das auch mit dir machen.
Und im Moment ist es zwar undenkbar, weil die USA und so sofort kommen würden,
aber wer weiß, was passiert, wenn Trump gewählt wird oder in fünf Jahren oder
in zehn Jahren kann man sich wirklich darauf verlassen, dass die USA hilft.
Und die Polen, obwohl sie der dickste Freund und großer Kunde in den USA sind, wissen,
wir brauchen eigenes Militär und eigene Waffen und haben deswegen ja auch mehrfach
das Thema wie bekloppt eingekauft in aller Welt,
insbesondere in Südkorea, aber auch in der USA.
Also haben Waffenkäufe getätigt, die bei Weitem alles übersteigen,
was Deutschland im Moment schafft, obwohl es viel größer ist.
Ja, also am Ende dieser Entwicklung werden wir definitiv sehen, dass die...
Stärksten Armeen neben Frankreich und Großbritannien, über deren Stärke man
sicherlich auch nochmal streiten kann,
aber die natürlich signifikant ist, weil es eigentlich mit den USA zusammen
die einzigen wirklichen internationalen Kräfte sind, mit ihren ganzen,
Schiffen, Flugzeugen, internationaler Infrastruktur und Standorten etc.
Das aber abgesehen von denen danach sofort Polen und die Ukraine dann kommen werden.
Das sind dann einfach so die stärksten Armeen auf jeden Fall.
Also man kann einfach sagen, was die Polen machen, ist so eine Art Trump-Proofing.
Trump-Proofing the Continent.
Einfach unabhängig von dem, was die USA jetzt gerade tun, sich auf eine Situation
vorzubereiten, wo einfach die USA nicht mehr da ist.
Und das ist natürlich etwas, was die ganze NATO tun sollte und Europa tun sollte.
Die Polen warten das aber nicht ab und das prägt dann eben den Diskurs in dieser
Gesamtdebatte und auch wenn wir natürlich jetzt in Deutschland diesen schlafmützigen Schulz da,
Scholz, ich hab schon seinen Namen vergessen,
Scholz und Merz, Zusammenschmerz.
Also da ist wenig zu erwarten und während Deutschland also seinen Dornröschenschlaf
noch ein paar Jahre fortsetzen wird, ist der Rest sich einfach gezwungen zu handeln.
Aber ich finde es halt auch interessant, wie das eben auch für eine ganz neue
Diskussion in den NATO-Ländern führt und die wird halt im Wesentlichen vorangetrieben vom Osteuropa,
außer eben Ungarn und Slowakei, dem Baltikum und Europa.
Natürlich den skandinavischen Ländern, die da alle eine ganz andere Sichtweise
drauf haben und auch eine ganz andere Preparedness haben.
Also auch Schweden und Finnland sind natürlich auch sehr, sehr starke Armeen.
Die hätte ich jetzt eigentlich mal, Finnland hätte ich eigentlich auch mal jetzt
mal auch noch mit reinnehmen müssen in diese Liste,
weil gemessen an ihrem Bruttosozialprodukt und vor allem auch gemessen an der
Anzahl von Einwohnern ist das die militärische Kapazität von Finnland auch nicht zu unterschätzen.
Also da ist auch richtig viel am Start.
Naja, aber wir wollen jetzt nicht so viel darüber reden, sondern mehr über was so passiert.
Ja, aber einen Satz muss ich noch loswerden.
Ja, leider gibt es in Deutschland einen starken Trend zum, was ich Unterwerfungspazifismus,
glaube ich, auch schon mal hier genannt habe.
Und ich finde das nach wie vor einen guten, prägnanten Begriff für das,
was da ja gerade von vielen propagiert wird, auch so Leuten à la Sarah Wagenknecht.
Aber auch, man muss sagen, auch Scholz fällt fast in dieses Camp.
Zumindest ist da keine klare Linie zu erkennen,
seit dieser Mann die Regierung übernommen hat.
Ja, ich meine, das fing an mit Gerede überhaupt in der deutschen Politik darüber,
dass die Ukraine nur Tage haben wird und dass man schon dabei war,
sich mit der Niederlage der Ukraine anzufreunden,
beziehungsweise er zunächst mal gar nicht so bestürzt erschien,
wie das eigentlich angemessen gewesen wäre.
Und seitdem hat man das Gefühl, stolpert Deutschland durch die Gegend.
Da wurde dieses 100-Milliarden-Feuerwerk noch abgebrannt, mit diesem Sonderfonds.
Aber im Grunde genommen war das auch einfach viel Gerede und auch eine ganze Menge Blendwerk.
Und ja, auf der einen Seite 100 Milliarden sind eine Menge Geld,
aber es ist deutlich weniger, als wenn man...
Einfach eine Quote festgesetzt hätte im Verhältnis zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt,
so einfach gesagt hätte,
okay, wir nehmen jetzt nicht 2%, sondern 2,5% oder 3% und das machen wir jetzt,
bis die Gefahr vorüber ist,
dann wären das hunderte von Milliarden in dem Zeitraum gewesen.
Ja, und nicht so ein einmaliger Schuss, der jetzt eigentlich schon,
ich meine, das Material ist zwar noch nicht da und so, aber das ist auch schwierig.
Du kaufst dann halt einen Haufen Zeugs und dann muss das natürlich auch noch
gewartet werden und dadurch entstehen natürlich auch Kosten und es ist immer, ja,
also so einmalige Sonderprogrammausgaben für jetzt eine Organisation sind eigentlich immer ein Anzeichen,
dass da erstens eine Menge schiefgegangen ist in der Vergangenheit,
dass man es zu sehr vernachlässigt hat.
Und sie deuten nicht auf nachhaltige Verbesserung hin.
Beispiel nur Berliner U-Bahn ist genau dasselbe.
Da wurden dann auch erst lange vernachlässigt, dann Riesenmengen an Geld zur
Neubeschaffung von Zeugs ausgegeben oder eingeplant.
Und jetzt nach zehn Jahren bricht es irgendwie gerade vollständig zusammen.
Hier das U-Bahn-System hat man das Gefühl. Und so habe ich das Gefühl,
wird auch mit der Bundeswehr umgegangen.
Aber okay, das war jetzt so ein kleiner Side-Rant.
Aber ja, ich bin nach wie vor unzufrieden.
Und es scheint aber nicht am Verteidigungsminister zu liegen,
der ein gutes Bild macht.
Aber der Kanzler ist einfach eine Flaube.
Ja, das kann man wohl sagen. Und der Rest der Regierung ist leider auch nicht
besser und die Opposition auch nicht.
Das Schlimmste an dieser Regierung ist, dass ich den Rest noch schlimmer finde.
Also man kann über die Regierung so enttäuscht sein, wie man will,
aber der Gedanke, dass irgendeiner von den anderen Flachpfeifen das Geschäft
übernehmen sollen würde, macht mich noch unruhiger.
Also das ist einfach alles nicht mehr zu fassen. Egal. Lass uns nicht so viel
über Deutschland reden.
Wir wollten ja ein bisschen internationale Politik machen. Lass uns vielleicht
mal nach Frankreich schauen.
Weil da gab es ja noch was ganz interessantes, was jetzt vielleicht erstmal
so mit dem Krieg direkt nichts zu tun hat.
Vielleicht, vielleicht doch. Man weiß es nicht so ganz genau.
Da gab es nämlich diese Festnahme von Paul Durow.
Wer ist Paul Durow? Paul Durow ist Gründer und Chef, kann man sagen,
von dem Dienst Telegram.
Und er ist festgenommen worden in Paris am 24.
August, als er dort eingereist ist. Er hat ja so ein ganzes Skatblatt voll von
Staatsbürgerschaften am Start, da kann er irgendwie alles mögliche ausspielen.
Er hat irgendwie einen russischen Pass, einen UAE-Pass, also Vereinigte Arabische
Emirate, sprich Abu Dhabi slash Dubai.
Er hat einen von St. Kitts und Nevis und er hat auch einen französischen Pass.
Was man sich alles so zusammen gekauft bekommt, wenn man genug Kohle hat.
Wenn man, genau, so als Milliardär kann man sich schon ein paar Staatsbürgerschaften leisten.
Ja, definitiv. Gehört auch zum guten Ton. Da braucht man immer irgendwie was,
wo man auch noch problemlos einreisen kann, falls es mal ein Problem gibt.
Keine Ahnung, wie er an die französische Staatsbürgerschaft rangekommen ist.
Wie auch immer hat ihm auf jeden Fall nicht viel geholfen, denn die Franzosen
hatten Beef mit ihm und haben halt offiziell zumindest beklagt,
dass Telegram ja so schwer zu erreichen ist,
wenn da mal Probleme sind,
so mit Verstößen gegen Gesetze zum Beispiel.
Und das ist ja so eine Story, die kennt man schon ein bisschen länger und dafür
ist ja Telegram auch berühmt, weil die
Grundhaltung von Pawel Durow war immer so, ja leck mich doch am Arsch,
mir doch egal, was ihr wollt, ich mache hier meinen Dienst, ich sitze hier in
Dubai, ihr könnt mir gar nichts,
und ich meine, wenn man in Dubai sitzt, dann ist schon mal klar,
dass wenn der Scheich da ankommt und sagt, hier.
Leute, die die was gegen Scheich sagen,
die hat es hier nicht zu geben. Du kannst mir viel erzählen,
aber dass der nicht mit dem Staatswesen der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate kooperiert,
das kann man einfach mal komplett ausschließen.
Das findet statt, weil sonst würde dieses Unternehmen dort nicht stattfinden.
Das ist einfach vollkommen undenkbar.
Und nur Frankreich hat halt nicht so einen Zugriff bisher gehabt,
bis der Herr dann beschlossen hat, da mal wieder zu landen. Weißt ja gar nicht,
wie lange er da nicht mehr war.
Na ja, dann haben sie ihn erstmal in Urhaft gesteckt und ist dann für ein paar
Millionen Dollar auf Kaution wieder freigekommen, darf das Land erstmal nicht verlassen.
Und hat jetzt auch angekündigt, dass Telegram ein paar Änderungen herbeiführen wird. Aha.
Ja, also mit der Erreichbarkeit für Behörden anderer Länder und vielleicht auch
mit der Durchsetzung bestimmter Regeln könnte durchaus sein,
dass sich da demnächst mal was ändert, weil der Milliardär wohl festgestellt
hat, dass Urhaft doch nicht so geil ist.
Ja, das ist die offizielle Version.
Ja, das ist die offizielle Version, genau. Und die habe ich jetzt wiedergegeben.
Also das ist das, was bekannt geworden ist und worum es vordergründig hier zu gehen scheint.
Jetzt kommen wir zu den Verschwörungstheorien.
Ja, ich habe dann tatsächlich mir mal die Mühe gemacht,
so ein bisschen tiefer zu graben, was denn da sonst noch so stattfindet und
inwieweit denn Dinge jetzt stimmen.
Und das mit der Erreichbarkeit, also es ist so,
dass Telegram sehr wohl in der Vergangenheit auch reagiert hat,
Wenn zum Beispiel so Dinge wie Kinderpornografie oder andere Sachen in den öffentlichen
Kanälen aufgetaucht sind,
da gab es genug Klagen von Leuten anderswo im Netz, die gesagt haben,
hier Telegram hat irgendwie meinen Kanal dicht gemacht oder die und die Kanäle
wurden jetzt dicht gemacht oder die und die Accounts wurden gebannt.
Und also es ist nicht so, dass jetzt auf Telegram irgendwie alles geht und die
jetzt dort jetzt wilder Osten,
Westen oder Süden oder wie auch immer geherrscht hat bisher. Ja, so.
Des Weiteren, so habe ich mir mal ein bisschen näher die Technik eigentlich
von Telegram angeschaut. So, worum geht es denn da?
Weil ich hatte ja auch mal so einen Messenger und kenne mich da ein bisschen
aus und deswegen hat mich das halt interessiert.
Und das Ding ist, dass Telegram per Default unverschlüsselt funktioniert.
Das heißt, wenn du ganz normal unter Telegram halt diese normalen Chats benutzt,
dann sind die unverschlüsselt.
Ein kleiner Einwurf, um das gleich klar zu machen.
Transportverschlüsselung gibt es sehr wohl. Also auf dem Weg zu den Servern
ist es verschlüsselt. Wenn du jetzt sagst, ist nicht verschlüsselt,
dann meinst du, ist nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt.
Genau.
Genau, also Transport verschlüsselt ist es zwar, aber liegt dann dort bei Telegram auf den Servern rum.
Jetzt sagt Telegram auch ja, aber wir verteilen das jetzt auch nochmal über verschiedene Server.
Sodass man die Daten mehrerer Server zusammenführen muss, um die Nachrichten
dort auch zu rekonstruieren.
Aber am Ende gibt es natürlich einen Server bei Telegram,
der in der Lage ist, diese Daten zusammenzuführen und sie wieder zu Klartext
zu machen und sie dann wieder transportverschlüsselt
an alle Clients zu schicken, die da berechtigt sind.
Mit anderen Worten, Telegram hat Zugriff auf die unverschlüsselten Chat-Daten.
So nennen wir es mal so.
Und Hacker potenziell auch, die die richtigen Systemteile angreifen.
Es gibt allerdings auch eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung in Telegram,
von der aber in der FAQ oder in Telegram eher abgeraten wird,
die zu benutzen, weil sie eine ganze Menge technische Einschränkungen hat.
Du kannst die Nachrichten nur auf dem Gerät sehen.
Wo sie empfangen wurden oder gesendet wurden und auf allen anderen Geräten nicht,
so wie das mit den normalen Telegram-Messages der Fall ist.
Plus das dann, achso, Thema Transportverschlüsselung,
also sowohl die Transportverschlüsselung als auch die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung,
da benutzt Telegram nicht standardmäßig etwa HTTPS.
Sondern MT-Proto 1 und MT-Proto 2, die dann so D4-Helmen-Key-Exchange selber machen.
Also im Grunde genommen haben sie HTTPS nochmal so ein bisschen nachimplementiert, wenn du so willst.
Und die eigentlichen Algorithmen, die sie benutzen, jetzt ist alles okay,
irgendwie SHA-256 und IS-256 jetzt nicht Military Grade,
aber soweit jetzt da ist nichts zu beanstanden.
Aber, ja, insgesamt dieser MT-Proto 1 und MT-Proto 2 kam es halt so,
Selbst gestrickt und relativ neu und nicht gut erforscht.
Ich habe da mal oberflächlich drauf geguckt, habe da jetzt nichts wirklich Falsches
gefunden, aber es sieht auch alles so ein bisschen hässlich aus und hat so eine
ganze Reihe von Beschränkungen.
Also es sieht ein bisschen primitiv aus, aber nicht irgendwie einfach oder elegant.
So, das war mein Eindruck, weil ich mir auch so ein bisschen die API angeguckt habe. Aber also so.
Und das Ding mit den sogenannten Secret Chats ist dann, ja, kann man erstmal
davon ausgehen, dass wahrscheinlich auch selbst Telegram dort keinen Einblick hat.
Aber sie werden extrem selten benutzt.
Also so selten, dass die Mac-Version zum Beispiel dieses Feature sie rausgenommen
haben, weil weniger als zwei Prozent der Nutzer das überhaupt je benutzt haben.
Also nicht, dass weniger als zwei Prozent jetzt der Nachrichten verschlüsselt
waren, sondern wahrscheinlich deutlich weniger.
Wie wenig weiß nur Telegram, aber unter einstelliger Prozentzahl.
Und damit, wenn du also in Telegram den Secret Chat benutzt,
flext du automatisch deine Daten als,
das sind wichtige und potenziell verdächtige Daten.
Und ich bin ein potenzieller Straftäter.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Also das, sozusagen technisch zu Telegram, das heißt, plus natürlich Telegram
hat natürlich auch, lade deine Telefonbuchdaten hoch,
das heißt, Telegram weiß auch, wer mit wem eigentlich in Kommunikation ist,
wer wen kennt, wer also dieselben Daten im Telefonbuch hat.
Das heißt, Telegram hat also auch selbst in den öffentlichen Daten ein komplettes
Werk kommuniziert mit wem von 80 Prozent der russischen Bevölkerung.
Ja, einschließlich des Großteils der Chats.
Das heißt, es sitzt irgendwie auf einem gewaltigen Datenschatz, was Russland betrifft.
Und das ist Russlands Messenger Nummer eins.
Ja, ist also aus dem täglichen Leben der meisten Russen nicht wegzudenken.
Offiziell hat so jeder dritte Russe einen Account dort.
Und die anderen zwei Drittel, keine Ahnung, haben vielleicht keine Handys oder
benutzen keine Messenger oder wie auch immer.
Also es ist jedenfalls das Ding und auch die russische Armee würde ohne große Probleme haben,
weil das auch Hauptkommunikationskanal der russischen Armee für alles ist,
was irgendwie auf dem kurzen Dienstweg besprochen werden muss. So.
Und das heißt, es ist ein Ding.
In der Ukraine ist im übrigen Telegramm nicht so viel benutzt,
aber ja, es ist halt politisch heikel.
So jetzt, Paul Durov, wie gesagt, ist zwar einerseits Russe,
aber lebt nicht in Russland und traut sich auch nicht, nach Russland zu reisen.
Gut, jetzt im Moment kann er nicht, aber wir hatten vorhin ja kurz erwähnt,
dass Putin in Aserbaidschan war nach der Invasion.
Und zur selben Zeit war auch Paul Durov in Aserbaidschan und es wurde gemunkelt,
was heißt mehr als gemunkelt, also gemunkelt.
Dass Durov sich mit Putin treffen wollte in Aserbaidschan.
Und das Munkel ging so weiter, dass Putin gesagt hat, er habe sich nicht mit ihm getroffen.
So ein Denial.
Ja, also diese...
Niemand hat die Absicht, sich mit Paul Durov zu treffen.
Ja, und als dann Durov nach Paris
geflogen ist, zurückgeflogen ist von Aserbaidschan, wurde er verhaftet.
So, kann natürlich alles Zufall gewesen sein, aber so meine These ist, ja,
es gibt diese Vorwürfe, es wird da wahrscheinlich auch unbeantwortete Anfragen gegeben haben.
So, das heißt, das wurde jetzt nicht frei erfunden, aber ich denke,
wäre Durovs Absicht, sich mit Putin zu treffen, nicht bekannt geworden,
hätte diese Verhaftung nicht stattgefunden.
Weil es gibt ja da erstmal noch andere, deutlich niederschwelligere Maßnahmen,
wenn du gegen einen Konzern vorgehst, als jetzt den CEO und Hauptgesellschaft zu verhaften.
Und ich denke, ja, man wollte in erster Linie von ihm wissen,
was er eigentlich von Putin gewollt hat und dass die ganze Sache eben damit in Verbindung steht.
Also dass es dort einen großen politischen Hintergrund gibt, auf jeden Fall.
Okay, also wie sein Verhältnis zu Putin ist, das weiß man nicht,
aber man weiß auf jeden Fall, wie das Verhältnis des russischen Militärs zu
Telegram ist. Das benutzen die nämlich alle.
Und das geht so weit, dass sie also nicht nur so private Chats drüber führen,
die Soldaten, sondern da werden halt auch komplette Einsätze koordiniert.
Jetzt haben die Russen ja so einiges an Erfahrung, was so Kommunikationsstörungen betrifft.
Das betreiben sie ja selber ganz gerne, da könnten wir eigentlich auch nochmal drauf eingehen.
Aber, weißt du, die haben kein funktionierendes Kommunikationssystem in ihrem
Militär und benutzen alle Telegram de facto.
Was ja auch schon öfter mal zu Problemen geführt hat,
wir erinnern uns zu Beginn des Krieges gab es ja dann auch so diverse Angriffe
der Ukraine auf Truppenkonzentrationen, wo halt alle irgendwie ihre Mobiltelefone
im ukrainischen Mobilfunknetz eingebucht haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was wir da mittlerweile machen, um das irgendwie zu verhindern.
Also worauf ich hinaus will ist, Telegram ist für Russland eine wichtige,
kritische Infrastruktur. De facto.
Ja.
Und weil die eben auch noch so unverschlüsselt ist, wie du das ja ausgeführt
hast, liegt quasi auf den Servern in Dubai...
Wobei ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob sie ihre Server alle in Dubai haben.
Vermutlich haben sie ihre Server auch weltweit, aber dann bestimmt auch besser
verschlüsselt als ihr eigentlicher Transport.
In diesen ganzen Gruppenchats, da liegen eine Menge Wahrheiten drin.
Und es ist halt wirklich die Frage, wer hat Zugriff auf diese Wahrheiten und
wer macht mit diesen Wahrheiten was.
Wer weiß da was, wer hat mit wem einen Deal, wer hat die Kontrolle über wen.
Das spielt eine Rolle. Das wollte ich einfach nur damit sagen und was auch noch
eine Rolle spielt in dem Zusammenhang mit Frankreich ist natürlich,
dass ja Frankreich mal abgesehen von dem generellen Konflikt,
den alle mit Russland haben wegen des Ukraine-Kriegs und weil halt Russland frei dreht,
sie ja auch nochmal spezifisch einen Beef haben mit den Russen,
weil sie ja auch diesen Fernkonflikt in Afrika austragen.
Also in den letzten zwei Jahren sind diverse Regierungen in Zentralafrika gekippt
und in Westafrika gekippt,
die für die ehemalige französische Kolonien sind und wo die Franzosen wichtige
Ressourcen von beziehen.
Die auch noch mit Frankreich in so einem afrikanischen Front,
in so einem Währungsverbund sind, was den Franzosen immer die Möglichkeit gegeben
hat, auf diese Ressourcen auch relativ krisenfest drauf zuzugreifen.
Mit anderen Worten, sie kaufen dort ihr Uran zu großen Teilen für den Betrieb
ihrer Atomkraftwerke, die irgendwie 90 Prozent der Strominfrastruktur in Frankreich sichern.
Und Russland schickt seine Wagner-Söldner, oder mittlerweile heißen sie ja nicht
mehr so, aber im Prinzip diese Söldnertruppen, die sie jetzt übernommen haben,
dort nach Afrika, um diesen Umstürzlern dort eben das Leben leicht zu machen.
Was für die ganz praktisch ist, weil die halt lieber mit russischen Söldnern
zusammenarbeiten als mit irgendwelchen Freiheitskämpfern aus eigenen tribalen Reihen,
weil die im Zweifelsfall dann immer wieder ihre Interessen auch noch selber vertreten wollen,
während die russischen Söldner halt eigentlich mit Afrika gar nichts am Hut haben.
Die wollen einfach nur Geld verdienen und hören im Wesentlichen auf das, was Putin sagt.
Und es ist eine weitere Konfliktlinie in diesem Gesamtprozess.
Wir können jetzt eigentlich relativ wenig feststellen, dass irgendwas irgendwie
ist. Wir wollen nur mal sagen...
Da ist mehr dahinter.
Da ist definitiv mehr dahinter.
Wir wissen jetzt nicht, in welchen Teilen jetzt Pavel Durov Asset von wem ist
oder inwieweit er ein freier Agent ist, der versucht,
sich irgendwie zwischen den Fronten zu bewegen.
Aber er ist auf jeden Fall ein Milliardär,
der sich in gefährlichen Gewässern bewegt und über kritische Informationen verfügt,
die das Begehren vieler geweckt haben dürften.
So kann man, glaube ich, die Situation charakterisieren und so richtig begeistert
scheinen, aber weder die Russen noch die Franzosen noch sonst wer mit ihm zu sein,
aber gut, man weiß es nicht.
Wo wir in dem Zusammenhang der russischen Kommunikationskultur sind,
vielleicht sollten wir auch noch mal so einen anderen Fall erwähnen,
der in den USA bekannt geworden ist, der für uns relativ wenig Überraschungen
geboten hat, aber wo es einfach glaube ich nochmal ganz interessant ist zu sehen,
wie Russland versucht, auf den Westen Einfluss zu nehmen.
Was dort bekannt geworden ist, was aufgedeckt worden ist, dass eine.
Ein Unternehmen in, ich habe gerade vergessen, welchem amerikanischen Bundesstaat das war, war das,
Kansas, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall gab es da ein Unternehmen,
das hieß Tenet Media, die so YouTube-Produzenten sind.
Aber halt so dem typischen Right-Wing-Lager in den USA zugeordnet werden können.
Das sind im Wesentlichen so sechs oder sieben verschiedene Akteure,
die dort eigene Kanäle haben,
die mehr oder weniger alle die gleiche Denke vertreten und die dann halt so
diesen ganzen üblichen rechtslastigen populistischen Republikaner Unsinn von sich geben,
den man da halt von überall hört. Also im Wesentlichen so die Trump-Linie.
Allerdings sind sie schon auch damit aufgefallen, dass sie das besonders extrem
taten. Mit anderen Worten, da gibt es also wirklich Folgen von diesen Leuten,
die einfach eins zu eins die Grimmel-Propaganda vorgelesen haben.
Das kann man nicht mehr anders sagen.
Und darüber hinaus, genau, somit die Ukraine ist der Feind, das gefährlichste
Land irgendwie auf der Welt und wir müssen ihnen sofort sämtliche Militärhilfen streichen und ja,
also wirklich sich da aufgeregt vor der Kamera und tatsächlich eben auch Kreml-Linie
durchgegeben und eine Menge Geld haben sie dafür bekommen.
Also so im Schnitt irgendwie 100.000 pro YouTube-Video oder nein, für die dafür,
100.000 dafür, für eine nicht exklusive Lizenz.
Ja, für Videos, die so zwischen 30.000 und 60.000 Views hatten.
Was zahlt uns die Ukraine eigentlich?
Tja, da muss ich doch mal gucken. Last time I checked. Ich schau mal kurz.
Ist noch nichts angekommen, leider. Ja, ja.
Jetzt machen wir das schon irgendwie seit zwei Jahren.
Immer noch nichts darüber gekommen. Mensch, Mensch, Mensch.
Ja, genau.
Nicht mal Pallianitia oder sowas.
Ja, ja, wir sind, genau, wir sind. Ja, nee, also es scheint jedenfalls sehr
lukrativ gewesen zu sein.
Nein, für die Leute, die natürlich nichts geahnt haben und natürlich jetzt sich als Opfer sehen.
Aber der Punkt ist, dass dort,
was immer nur so vermutet oder in den Raum gestellt wurde,
jetzt quasi erstmals in Form einer offiziellen Schrift...
Dokumentiert worden ist.
Dokumentiert wurde und ja, es jetzt Ermittlungen gibt und es möglicherweise
zu Verfahren kommen wird.
Und was aber in dem Zuge bekannt wurde, ist,
dass das FBI wohl etwa 1000 Online-Personen.
Ja unter Beobachtung hat,
wo sie ausgehen, dass sie direkt unter russischem Einfluss stehen und russisch
gesteuerte Propaganda verbreiten.
So im In- und Ausland allerdings waren wohl diese tausend Kanäle oder tausend
Personen, die sie beobachten, was halt natürlich heißt,
dass es vermutlich deutlich mehr gibt, aber das sind die Zahlen, die dort gefallen sind.
Und ja, das findet natürlich auch massiv in Deutschland statt,
kann man auch von ausgehen, dass
hier mit Hilfe russischer Gelder auch politische Parteien, Kandidaten,
Journalisten,
Online-Persönlichkeiten und, und, und unterstützt werden auf unterschiedlichsten Wegen.
Und nicht mal alle davon vielleicht wirklich unbedingt wissen oder wissen wollen.
Und nur sehen, dass da plötzlich scheinbar leicht verdientes Geld zu holen ist.
Und ja, dass einfach viele Leute bereit sind, so...
Sich ihre Stimme für Geld zu verkaufen.
Und das in einem moralisch mehr als fragwürdigen Zusammenhang.
Ja, absolut. Also ich meine, die Russen brüsten sich ja selber im Fernsehen
damit mit diesen Aktivitäten.
Also konkret wurde ja hier die Verbindung als Zahlungsquelle zu Russia Today hergestellt.
In Nachgang dazu hat jetzt auch Facebook eingesehen, dass sie vielleicht jetzt
mal Russia Today Channel verbannen sollten, auch noch ein anderer Dienst,
den ich jetzt gerade vergessen habe.
Und ja, so läuft das gerade ab.
Also man muss sich einfach klar machen, dass die russische Propaganda einfach
versucht alles zu infiltrieren,
was in irgendeiner Form normaler Diskurs ist in Deutschland, in Europa, weltweit.
Und es ihnen vor allem auch in sehr vielen Ländern gelingt und wenn es auch
nur teilweise gelingt und wenn es auch teilweise in einem Maße,
passiert, wo man sich denkt was kann das schon groß auslösen,
ja also YouTube Videos, die 60.000 Views haben.
Das ist ja quasi nichts, ja also die haben sich da jetzt nicht die Top Leute
geholt Aber darum geht es ja auch gar nicht.
Es geht nicht darum, irgendeinen dominanten Kanal zu bespielen,
sondern es geht immer um die Zerstörung des Diskurses.
Und die Zerstörung des Diskurses, wie er ja auch in Russland selber stattfindet
und seit Jahren von Putin erfolgreich betrieben wird, ist eben die Methode, dass du einfach so viel….
Unterschiedliche Erklärungen und Standpunkte zu irgendeinem Ding,
was auch immer es ist, ja, und auch so viele mögliche Verschwörungstheorien
in jeder beliebigen Wahnsinnsstufe verbreitest, bis einfach alle abschalten
und sagen, ich glaube jetzt gar nichts mehr.
Weil, wenn du nämlich gar nichts mehr glaubst, dann glaubst du nämlich auch
nicht, wie es wirklich war.
Dann kann dir keiner mehr darlegen, guck mal genau, so ist die Situation,
Da müssen wir jetzt mal was machen.
Nee, ich habe ja gehört, dass es so sein kann und ich habe gehört,
dass es so sein kann und ich habe gehört, dass es so sein kann.
Und dann landest du eben auch genau bei dem Zustand der heutigen russischen
Bevölkerung, die sich halt einfach aus allem nur noch raushalten will.
Weil sie einfach gelernt hat, dass das sozusagen ihr die beste Überlebensstrategie ist für sie.
Ja, und auch das Schüren von Unzufriedenheit und Hass und Empörung durch natürlich
dann so erfundene Rage-Stories,
die dann einfach Entrüstung auslösen, in der Regel frei erfunden.
Ja, das bleibt immer hängen. Also ich weiß noch, als ich irgendwie neulich mal
in Budapest war und dann irgendwie im Taxi gefahren bin, dann haben die Taxifahrer
auch gefragt, wie sieht es aus hier, Ukraine, lalala.
Und dann so, hm, hm, hm, ja, weiß nicht.
Wo ich mich schon so ein bisschen wundere so. Ich meine, das ist irgendwie ein
Nachbarland von der Ukraine.
Ja, aber man hört ja auch immer so Sachen und die Ukrainer haben ja dann hier,
was weiß ich, auch Ungarn gefoltert und keine Ahnung und die Russen auf der
Krim und das ist mir so, äh.
Also so Storys und da war mir schon klar, wo es herkommt.
In Ungarn muss man sich da jetzt eh nicht groß wundern, aber es ist halt auch
in Deutschland nichts anderes.
Du findest halt immer schnell irgendwelche hanebüchenen Storys,
die rausgezogen werden und wo kommen die her?
Aus irgendwelchen YouTube-Kanälen, die halt nicht viele Views haben müssen,
um als Beleg in irgendwelchen Telegram-Gruppen zu landen, wo die Bubbles unter sich sind.
Und da geht es einfach nur darum, dass Material da ist, der quasi eine weitere
Sichtweise, die gerade passt, bestärkt wird.
Und so funktioniert eben dieser Propaganda-Apparat auf so einer globalen Ebene
und das funktioniert da auch super.
Da muss man sich nicht wundern, warum dann Länder wie Südafrika Amerika und
überhaupt viele afrikanische Länder und auch Brasilien irgendwie überhaupt gar
keine klare Haltung zu diesem Ukraine-Konflikt entwickeln können,
weil einfach die Bevölkerung nicht weiß, was sie glauben soll oder einfach auch
wirklich generell so die russische Sicht glaubt.
Da kommen natürlich noch andere Faktoren mit rein, mit BRICS und die Abhängigkeit
vom Öl und generell natürlich auch eine anti-westliche Stimmung,
weil ja nun die Amerikaner und auch Europa,
sagen wir mal, weil diese Länder jetzt auch nicht gerade besonders Blenden behandelt
hat in den letzten Jahrzehnten und Jahrhunderten.
Und da muss man sich jetzt auch mal nicht wundern, wenn man da mit seinen Thesen
dann nicht ankommt und sagt so, ja, bei uns brennt aber hier die Hütte.
So, ja, bei uns brennt die Hütte schon seit Jahrhunderten, das hat euch noch
nie interessiert. Jetzt sollen wir euch auf einmal helfen, so kommt mal klar.
Das kommt natürlich jetzt auch noch mal mit rein. Nur, klar,
man will ja am Ende auch einen ordentlichen Diskurs haben, aber daran hat halt
Russland einfach gar kein Interesse.
Und deswegen sind solche Geschichten.
Also es ist einfach eine Sache, die real ist, die passiert und die man zur Kenntnis nehmen sollte.
Gut, kommen wir vielleicht zu unserem letzten Block.
Die Wirtschaft. Die Wirtschaft, denn es ist ja eine große Diskussion generell
jetzt und damit sind wir auch in gewisser Hinsicht beim Ausblick auf den Krieg
und die nächste Zukunft.
Die große Frage, die sich alle immer wieder stellen ist, wie lange halten die
beiden Kombatanten hier durch?
Wie lange kann die Ukraine sich wirtschaftlich am Leben erhalten,
um den entsprechenden Widerstand zu finanzieren?
Wie lange kann Russland sein System am Leben erhalten und diesen Angriffskrieg finanzieren?
Und würde irgendeiner von den beiden aufgeben müssen, wenn das nicht mehr der Fall ist?
Ja, wir lagen anfangs,
waren wir ja eher etwas optimistisch, was einen wirtschaftlichen Zusammenbruch
Russlands oder Niedergang Russlands angeht.
Ich kann mich erinnern, dass nach den Sanktionen so die Überlegung war,
naja, so in drei Monaten im Sommer, so wird es dann für Russland richtig eng werden.
Aber, ja...
Ähm, das ist nicht eingetreten. Und jetzt kürzlich… Moment.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir gesagt haben, dass es eng wird, wir haben nur gesagt, es wird schon sauteuer.
Sauteuer ist es auf jeden Fall geworden. Nur die Bereitschaft,
dieses sauteure Unternehmen und Unterfangen weiterhin zu betreiben und sogar
noch irgendwie auf elf zu drehen, hat uns teilweise überrascht.
Aber du hast schon recht, die Wahrnehmung der Macht einer wirtschaftlichen Sanktion
beziehungsweise der Überforderung eines Landes durch Krieg, die haben wir sicherlich überschätzt.
Ja, die Tanks versus Banks, wobei, ja.
Es ist auch nicht so, dass es jetzt keinen Einfluss auf Russland hat.
Nein, nein, nein, das nicht. Aber so jetzt steht ja wieder mal im Raum,
dass der ukrainische Geheimdienstchef Budanov gesagt hat, dass Russland versuchen wird,
den Krieg in 2025 zu gewinnen oder keine andere Wahl hat,
als das zu versuchen, Weil es danach wirtschaftlich und militärisch rapide schwächer werden wird.
Das hat er jetzt in den Raum gestellt und das dann auch versucht zu begründen.
Und wenn man dem dann nachgeht, ist es in der Tat so, dass die russische Wirtschaft
auf einem Pfad ist, der nicht dauerhaft durchzuhalten ist.
Und ein Problem hat sich dieses Jahr jetzt manifestiert, nachdem in den ersten
beiden Jahren die russische Wirtschaft besser gelaufen ist, als alle das vermutet
oder erwartet hatten. Ähm.
Jetzt ist die Inflation extrem hoch und zwar trotz hoher Zentralbankzinsen,
die dem eigentlich entgegenwirken sollen.
Also der Effekt, warum man, um die Inflation in den Griff zu kriegen,
die Zentralbankzinsen erhöht, ist, dass dadurch Kredite teurer werden,
dass dadurch die Nachfrage sinkt, dass dadurch die wirtschaftliche Aktivität
und die Investitionen sinken und dass sich dann dadurch die Situation stabilisiert.
Das dann, sagen wir mal, weniger Nachfrage, dann werden die Produkte nicht mehr teurer.
So, weniger Kreditgeld im System,
ja, Umlaufgeschwindigkeit des Geldes reduziert sich, wie auch immer.
So, und das funktioniert in der Regel auch, das funktioniert fast überall.
Das hat in Deutschland jetzt funktioniert, das funktioniert jetzt in den USA.
Zinsen rauf, warten bis Inflation sinkt, dann Zinsen wieder runter.
Und so versucht man eigentlich auf 3% Inflationsrate sich einzupendeln.
Das ist so der anerkannte ideale Wert aus verschiedensten Gründen.
Man will halt auf 3% runterkommen.
Zwei. Zwei bis drei. Also Christiane Lagarde, die EZB-Präsidentin, sagt zwei.
Gut, also Geschmackssache, aber in der Größenordnung.
Also man will ein bisschen, also das ist ja sozusagen das Geheimnis der Inflation.
Inflation wird ja immer generell als sowas, oh Inflation ganz schlimm,
ganz grausam und so weiter.
Nee, also gar keine Inflation ist auch nicht gut. Man will, dass immer alles
ein bisschen teurer wird, damit du dein Geld nicht hortest.
Damit du einen Anreiz hast, es auszugeben, damit du es eben in Umlauf bringst,
dass eben die Wirtschaft auch bedient wird.
Weil wenn alle, die ihr Geld besitzen, es einfach nur behalten,
dann kriegt keiner mehr was davon ab.
Und das ist auch nicht gut. Und deswegen muss immer eine leichte Verteuerung da sein.
Sie darf bloß eben nicht so hoch sein, dass die Löhne dem nicht folgen können
und es dann für die Leute zu teuer wird.
Ist eine Inflation zu hoch, dann galoppieren die Preise davon,
ohne dass die Löhne dort mithalten und dann wird es eben teuer und das können
sich dann eben nur die Reichen leisten.
Das ist so ein bisschen das, was man immer im Kopf haben muss,
aber die Inflationssituation und auch die Kreditsituation in Russland ist halt
so, die Inflation ist hoch, aber die Inflation wird eben immer gemessen an allem.
Man stellt so einen Produktkorb quasi zusammen,
man beobachtet verschiedene Faktoren, was kostet die Butter,
was kostet das Salz, was kostet der Zucker, was kosten andere Dinge des Lebens,
die die Leute gerne viel kaufen, was kostet ein Big Mac, was kostet ein Fernseher etc.
Und darüber trackt man sozusagen die Preisentwicklung und natürlich gehören
da auch so Sachen dazu wie Energiekosten etc.
Manche Sachen bedienen das eben schneller, andere brauchen eine Weile bis sie sich erhöhen,
aber das ist halt auch unterschiedlich verteilt, je nachdem wo eben die wirtschaftliche
Aktivität vielleicht gerade stockt oder besonders aufgedreht ist.
Und ja, die Inflationsrate, je nachdem offiziell,
also liegt in Russland so bei über 10%, teilweise 20% in bestimmten Bereichen.
Und das aber schon seit einer geraumen Weile.
Und trotz entsprechend hoher Zinsen, also mehrfacher Zinserhöhungen jetzt von
der Zentralbank, geht die Inflation nicht runter.
Und der Grund dafür ist aber auch ganz einfach,
weil eigentlich sollen ja jetzt diese hohen Zinsen verhindern,
dass irgendwie mehr Geld in die Wirtschaft gepumpt wird.
So gleichzeitig pumpt aber
der russische Staat massiv Gelder in die Wirtschaft durch den Krieg und steuert
auf dieser Weise dem entgegen und reduziert damit eigentlich nur private Aktivität,
aber weitet damit eben die Inflation aus durch hohe Soldatengehälter.
Durch hohe Gehälter für Leute in Rüstungsfirmen und hohe Rüstungsausgaben.
Und dafür wird, das ist teilweise Defizit getrieben, beziehungsweise gab es
halt noch gewisse Ersparnisse,
die Russland noch hatte und da ist man halt rangegangen.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass die Rüstungsausgaben für den Staat nicht mit steigenden
Preisen versehen sind, weil die werden einfach zum Festpreis gekauft.
Trotz alledem, dass die hohe Nachfrage nach Personal einerseits in diesen Rüstungsbetrieben,
weil dadurch, dass jetzt quasi das Land auf Kriegswirtschaft umgestellt hat,
benötigen diese ganzen produzierenden Unternehmen,
also die in irgendeiner Form primär oder sekundär in diesem Rüstungsgeschäft mit drin sind.
Also die Fabriken, die Panzer bauen, die ganzen Fahrzeuge bauen,
die sonstiges Material bauen, die natürlich allen voran, aber natürlich auch
alle Zulieferer entsprechender Basistechnologien, Ressourcen etc.
Die brauchen jetzt natürlich auch, um diesen Apparat hochzufahren auf den Kriegsmodus, mehr Personal.
Da aber der Staat gleichzeitig auch Soldaten benötigt und das derzeit nicht
über Mobilisierung erledigt, sondern eben auch über finanzielle Anreize und
dabei die Preise immer weiter steigen.
Also heute werden irgendwie neu in die Armee eintretenden Soldaten,
ich weiß nicht ganz genau in welchen Bereichen, aber ihnen wird sozusagen schon
ein Handgeld mitgegeben, was irgendwie so einem Jahres- oder Zweijahreseinkommen
normalerweise entspricht.
Und das ist natürlich für viele Leute einfach super interessant und deswegen
schaffen sie es immer wieder noch weiteres Material an die Front zu bekommen.
Also Menschenmaterial, ich weiß es ist ein furchtbarer Begriff,
aber im Falle der russischen Armee greift leider auch glaube ich zu Recht kein anderer Begriff mehr.
Und diese Leute, die dort also für sehr viel Geld vom Staat eingekauft werden,
die kommen ja nicht aus dem Nichts, sondern die fehlen der Wirtschaft,
die auf der anderen Seite auch gerade mit einer niedrigen Arbeitslosigkeit zu kämpfen hat.
Weil sie brauchen halt Personal und es ist überhaupt gar kein Problem,
derzeit Jobs zu finden, weil so viele Jobs frei werden durch so viele Soldaten,
vor allem bei jungen Männern, im besten Alter sozusagen,
im Idealfall auch noch gut ausgebildet, die halt die ganze Zeit in diesem Krieg verheizt werden.
Entweder an der Frontlinie oder hinter der Frontlinie. Mit anderen Worten,
jetzt sind auch diese Unternehmen.
Gezwungen, immer höhere Löhne zu zahlen, damit sie überhaupt noch mithalten
können mit dem Konkurrenten-Soldaten-Job.
Und das wiederum bedeutet, dass auf der einen Seite sehr viel Geld wiederum
in die Bevölkerung kommt,
die diese Inflation, die existiert, so nicht spürt, weil sie ja mehr Geld haben.
Und sich damit eben auch höhere Lebensmittelpreise etc.
Noch leisten können. Auch wenn es natürlich schon viele Leute im Land gibt,
die sich das so nicht mehr so gut leisten können, weil sie an diesem Geldtransfer
so unmittelbar nicht teilnehmen, sondern bestenfalls nur mittelbar daran teilnehmen.
Aber so hält sich sozusagen das Ganze gerade noch ein wenig die Waage und führt eben noch nicht dazu,
dass das Land insgesamt dagegen aufsteht, dagegen protestiert oder diese Situation
als untragbar markiert,
sondern es ist halt einfach so und es gleicht sich eben dadurch aus,
solange der Staat immer noch mehr Geld reinpumpt und sich das irgendwie noch
halbwegs ausbalanciert.
Die Frage ist, was passiert, wenn das dann alles nicht mehr so funktioniert,
wenn also das Ganze auch an seine Grenzen kommt, an die es unter Umständen auch
bald kommt, weil der Staat entweder die Kohle nicht mehr hat oder nicht mehr
die Bereitschaft hat, mehr zu zahlen.
So genau, das ist im Prinzip auch das, so wie Anders Puck Nielsen das,
glaube ich, dargestellt hat und auch andere.
Und wie gesagt, Budanov war ja der Erste, der diese These jetzt aufgestellt hat.
Also nächstes Jahr 2025 muss Russland umsteuern und wird in Probleme reinlaufen.
Also kann den Kurs, den es jetzt fährt, nur noch maximal bis Mitte, Ende 2025 fahren.
Und ich habe mich dann gefragt...
Was sagen denn die offiziellen Zahlen? Also abseits jetzt von Kommentatoren,
was sagt denn die Statistik?
Und laut der russischen Zentralbank,
wenn man der Glauben schenkt und das Internet und die internationalen Experten
scheinen diesen Zahlen Glauben zu schenken, Also wenn man diese Zahlen recherchiert,
findet man überall praktisch die offiziellen Zahlen der russischen Zentralbank.
Niemand zweifelt die an.
Ich weiß es nicht, die können oder können nicht richtig, sind vielleicht richtig,
vielleicht aber auch nicht.
Aber nehmen wir mal jetzt allein die russischen Zahlen, die eben allgemein verwendet werden.
Dann hat die russische Zentralbank für
2024 erwartet sie insgesamt ein Wirtschaftswachstum von 3,5 bis 4 Prozent,
also inflationsbereinigt.
Das wäre ein solides Wachstum,
nicht großartig, aber so für 2025 werden jetzt nur noch 0,5 bis 1,5 Prozent
erwartet von der russischen Zentralbank selbst.
Also die russische Zentralbank sagt auch, okay, nächstes Jahr wird nicht so dolle werden.
Aber man kann jetzt sagen, naja, 0,5 bis 1,5 Prozent ist immer noch mehr als
Deutschland dieses Jahr hat.
Wo wir irgendwie wahrscheinlich bei 0 oder 0,1 Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum rauslaufen werden.
Aber, so, ja gut,
guckt man sich jetzt auch die Zahlen an, was denn jetzt so Haushaltsdefizite
und Neuverschuldung und so angeht, kann man sagen,
ja, Russland fährt Haushaltsdefizite in signifikanter Größenordnung so,
aber jetzt auch nicht katastrophal.
Und die Verschuldung ist jetzt auch nicht so hoch, weil Russland hatte halt
kaum Schulden und aus dem Leid kaum jemand Russland was.
Also insofern, gut, verschuldet der Staat sich vielleicht doch bei den Bürgern und so.
Also wenn man jetzt rein auf die Zahlen guckt, so sieht es jetzt nicht so aus,
als wenn jetzt ein Kollaps irgendwie der russischen Wirtschaft im nächsten Jahr ansteht.
Und man kann jetzt natürlich auch noch argumentieren, dass ja.
Russland wird Dinge ändern müssen und es hat sich bisher auch recht gut angepasst
an geänderte Rahmenbedingungen so und dürfte es vielleicht oder wahrscheinlich
wieder tun so im nächsten Jahr.
Also wieder mit irgendwas halt ankommen und Dinge ändern.
Aber, und jetzt kommt zu sagen, dass aber, während die Zahlen einerseits jetzt ganz gut aussehen.
Sind Änderungen, also die Änderungen, die anstehen, dürften unpopulär sein.
Also es sind ja keine populären Änderungen zu erwarten und ja,
das könnte dann insgesamt wahrscheinlich die Unterstützung der Bevölkerung für
den Krieg weiter senken.
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt schon bei 48 Prozent und wie sieht es erst aus,
wenn ja im nächsten Jahr dann unpopuläre Maßnahmen bekommen müssen,
die jetzt zwar nicht wirtschaftlich ruinös sind, aber schon spürbar für alle,
die es jetzt noch nicht zu spüren gekriegt haben. So.
Und außerdem könnten die Änderungen, wie es so schön heißt, weil Dinge zu sogenannten
krisenhaften Anpassungserscheinungen führen, also dass Dinge einfach kaputt
gehen dabei durch die Änderungen und so.
Und auf der anderen Seite, als ich mir die ganzen Zahlen angeguckt habe und
die wirtschaftliche Situation, bin ich zu der Erkenntnis gekommen,
dass Putin und Russland es sich wirtschaftlich wunderbar leisten könnten,
sich komplett aus der Ukraine zurückzuziehen.
Selbst wenn diese Aktionen aufrechterhalten würden.
Selbst unter den Bedingungen würde Russland jetzt nicht untergehen wirtschaftlich.
In der Realität, wenn aber jetzt die Stimmung umschwingt und Putin zu der Erkenntnis
kommt, der Krieg ist nicht zu gewinnen,
wird er sicherlich einige Konzessionen raushandeln können, So wie,
ja, die bisher besetzten russischen Gebiete werden entmilitarisiert,
kommen zwar unter ukrainische Verwaltung,
da ist dann Polizei und alles meinetwegen, aber es dürfen dort keine schweren
Waffen oder Raketen oder Artillerie stationiert werden.
Dann könnte Putin hingehen und zu Hause auch noch vermelden, Operation gelungen,
so ist entmilitarisiert, wir ziehen uns jetzt wieder zurück und na gut,
mit dem Kleinen, dass wir es annektiert haben und so, das vergessen wir mal,
das schmeißen wir mal unter den Tisch.
Ja, nicht, dass er es tun wird. Ich sage nur, wenn er zu der Erkenntnis käme und es tun wollte, ja.
Wäre er wahrscheinlich in der Lage und dann noch die Aufhebung der Sanktionen
schrittweise so mit dazu.
Alle wären wieder glücklich und Putin könnte weitermachen mit der Unterwanderung des Westens,
mithilfe von Geld und Oligarchen und alle wären wieder glücklich und das Geld
würde wieder sprudeln und die russische Wirtschaft würde boomen.
So, weil Russland ist halt eine Öldiktatur, wenn man so will,
eine Öl- und Rohstoffdiktatur und eigentlich das Einzige, was im Moment, was dann zählen würde,
ist, dass wieder genug Öl gepumpt und Gas geliefert wird und dann fließt das
Geld wieder und alle werden glücklich.
Ja, das wäre sozusagen eine Lösung.
Also das ist das Szenario durchaus, was im Moment nicht realistisch ist,
aber wo in einem Jahr wir mal wieder drüber reden können, wo wir dann dort sind oder in zwei Jahren.
Und ich halte das nicht für komplett abwegig, ein solches Szenario.
Wenn, wie gesagt, da sind wir noch lange nicht, aber Putin merkt,
nee, es geht so nicht weiter.
Um es mal vielleicht ein bisschen kompakter zusammenzufassen,
die Situation in Russland ist zwar hart für Russland, aber noch nicht so,
dass es sie in die Knie zwingt.
Aber auf dem Pfad, auf dem sie
sich gerade befinden, können sie auch nicht beliebig lange weitermachen.
Ob es jetzt 2025 ist oder 2026 oder vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen später,
entzieht sich meiner Kenntnis und ich glaube, das entzieht sich auch der Kenntnis
vieler Experten, die schon immer ein bisschen daneben geliegen haben.
Es kann aber genauso gut auch schneller gehen.
Die Frage ist ja auch immer, wie viel ist quasi auch dieses Staatsgebilde als
Ganzes bereit zu leiden, beziehungsweise wann steigen Putin die Eliten aus,
weil wenn die halt irgendwann ihre Fälle davon schwimmen sehen,
das ist so der Punkt, wo sie dann eben ihren Support auch einstellen.
Vielleicht nicht gleich so in der Revolution, aber dann wird es auf jeden Fall
kritisch, weil er kann zwar viel machen, aber er ist jetzt auch nicht komplett unabhängig von allen.
Aber auf jeden Fall, und das räumt selbst die russische Zentralbank ein,
erwartet sie einen Tiefpunkt im Jahre 2025 und zwar den tiefsten Tiefpunkt seit
Beginn des Krieges wirtschaftlich gesehen, sagt die russische Zentralbank.
So selbst.
Und auch wenn der Tiefpunkt jetzt und wir kommen gleich zur Ukraine nicht so
ein Einbruch ist wie bei der ukrainischen Invasion,
deutet alles darauf hin dass tatsächlich 2025 sich etwas verändern wird in Russland.
Etwas Größeres.
Ja, muss man nur so lange noch durchhalten, um da vielleicht dann auch einen Nutzen draus zu ziehen.
Schauen wir doch mal auf die Ukraine, wie es dort aussieht, denn da sind ja
die wirtschaftlichen Verhältnisse ganz anders.
Ja, also ich habe halt auf Statista vergleichbare Zahlen gefunden für Ukraine und Russland,
was so die Entwicklung des Bruttoinlandsprodukts angeht.
Und was jetzt die Ukraine betrifft, gab es halt in 2022 einen massiven Einbruch von fast 30 Prozent.
Was natürlich einmal damit zu tun hat, dass Territorium und Bevölkerung verloren
gegangen sind und auch Territorium, wo sich größere Produktionsstätten befunden haben.
Also nicht nur ein paar Agrarflächen, wobei auch die in signifikantem Umfang
natürlich eingebüßt wurden.
Und dann sind schlichtweg auch 10, 15 Millionen Ukrainer ins Ausland gegangen,
die auch nicht mehr zur wirtschaftlichen Aktivität beitragen innerhalb der Ukraine.
Insofern sind diese 30 Prozent natürlich erstmal ein krasser Niedergang.
Aber das Ganze bedeutete dann nicht den wirtschaftlichen Kollaps der Ukraine,
weil ab 2023 das Wachstum in der Ukraine tatsächlich höher war als in Russland.
Und zwar deutlich.
Und eben auch weiter Wachstum, also deutlich höheres Wachstum,
als in Russland prognostiziert wird.
Und für 2025, Gegenteil von dem, was Russland angeht, das sich im Tief befinden wird,
geht man für die Ukraine von über 6,5% Wirtschaftswachstum aus.
Aber...
Es ist jetzt nicht nur das Wachstum, sondern auch alle anderen wirtschaftlichen
Kenndaten, auf die man drauf guckt,
wie zum Beispiel die Inflationsrate,
die bei 5% liegt, weniger als die Hälfte von dem in Russland,
und ein Basiszins von 12 Prozent,
auch die Hälfte von dem, was in Russland der Fall ist.
Man ist zwar noch zwei Prozent von den dreien entfernt oder drei Prozent von den zweien.
Dann ist aber auch positiv zu berichten, dass die Reform und die Europäisierung
in der Ukraine voranschreitet.
Und die Ukraine die quantitativen Performance-Kriterien vom IMF,
also acht von neun dieser Kriterien erfüllt oder übererfüllt hat.
Das heißt, das sind so Kennzahlen wie das Mindeststeueraufkommen,
was die Ukraine selber einnehmen muss, Verschuldungsgrenzen,
Obergrenzen, die einzuhalten sind.
Ausgabengrenzen, die einzuhalten sind und der Aufbau von Devisenreserven zum Beispiel.
Und in all diesen Punkten hat die Ukraine erfüllt und übererfüllt.
Also insofern kann man sagen,
zeigen trotz des Krieges die
wirtschaftlichen Daten in der Ukraine in eine absolut positive Richtung.
Positiver als die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung in Russland, erstaunlicherweise.
Natürlich alles unter Bedingungen jetzt auch internationaler Unterstützung.
Ohne die wäre ein Wachstum in der Größenordnung wahrscheinlich nicht möglich.
Aber man kann sagen, dass die Ukraine einen signifikanten Teil des Geldes für
den Krieg auch selbst erwirtschaftet und aufbringt.
Das zeigen halt diese Zahlen im Moment.
Und das fand ich halt wirklich überraschend so.
Auf der anderen Seite ist jetzt natürlich nicht alles Friede,
Freude, Eierkuchen und 25 Prozent der Bevölkerung sind unter die Armutsgrenze gerutscht.
Also durch den Krieg letztlich.
Das war mal besser.
Aber klar, wenn Leute halt aus ihren Dörfern vertrieben werden und irgendwo
anders unterkommen müssen, dann hat das natürlich Auswirkungen.
Oder einfach die Zerstörung von Lebensgrundlagen, von privatem Eigentum.
Stehen dann Leute plötzlich mittellos da oder die vielleicht auf Mieteinnahmen angewiesen waren,
vielleicht irgendwie eine Eigentumswohnung irgendwo finanziert hatten und von
den Mieteinnahmen dann gelebt haben und das Ding wird denen einfach weggebombt.
Und da zahlt dann auch nicht unbedingt eine Versicherung oder in der Regel keine
Versicherung bei Kriegsschäden. Ja.
Und insofern, ja, es ist auf der einen Seite, kann man sagen, wow, super,
die Ukraine entwickelt sich wirtschaftlich gut, aber sie braucht halt unsere
Hilfe und ist längst nicht irgendwie in der Region,
wo dieses Land sein sollte oder sein könnte wirtschaftlich.
Zumal da einfach viel Potenzial ist in der Ukraine, weil es ist ein großes Land
also wenn man sich jetzt mal den Krieg mal wegdenkt,
ja und einfach mal nur so auf das Land schaut, es ist technologisch ähm,
Teilweise sehr weit entwickelt in bestimmten Feldern.
Also insbesondere was so Software, Computersysteme betrifft, da sind sie richtig gut.
Sie haben einen riesigen Agrarsektor und durch das Land natürlich auch eine
ganze Menge Potenzial im Energiesektor zum Beispiel.
Also was da an Flächen verfügbar ist für Solarkraftwerke, dann haben sie ohnehin
die Atomkraftwerke. okay, die müssten natürlich jetzt befreit werden.
Und sie hatten massive auch Stromerzeugungskapazitäten für die Schwerindustrie, die sich dort befand.
Also, ja, und da kommen wir jetzt gleich vielleicht noch kurz drauf, wie das halt.
Welche Dimensionen und Auswirkungen jetzt eigentlich die Angriffe auf die ukrainische Infrastruktur haben.
Okay, wie kriegen die das hin, wo doch die Russen eigentlich das gesamte Energienetz
zerbomben und ohne Strom kannst du halt auch nichts produzieren.
Und bei Perun, glaube ich, habe ich jetzt Zahlen gefunden, sie stammen von der
Ukraine ursprünglich, auch von Budanov,
glaube ich, dass insgesamt bisher 9600 Raketen auf die Ukraine abgefeuert wurden,
wovon 2.430 abgefangen wurden und 7.170 durchgekommen sind.
Also über 7.000 Raketen sind irgendwo in der Ukraine eingeschlagen.
Und dazu kamen 14.000 Drohnen, von denen 9.270, also 4.739 durchgekommen.
Also insgesamt nach 11.500 Raketen und Drohnen sind in der Ukraine eingeschlagen.
Dazu natürlich jede Menge Artillerie und Kurzstrecken.
Also das sind alles jetzt Langstreckenraketen, die irgendwo tief ins Land hineingegangen sind.
So und zur Hälfte ungefähr militärische Ziele und zur Hälfte zivile Ziele wie Energieanlagen,
Kraftwerke, Umspannstationen, Brücken und so weiter getroffen haben. So und.
Was jetzt die Energieinfrastruktur angeht, ist der Hauptgrund,
warum die Ukraine noch halbwegs Strom hat, trotz dann je nachdem auch hoher Ausfälle ist,
dass eben das Energiesystem der Ukraine massive Überkapazitäten hatte.
Also gewaltig dimensioniert war
und selbst jetzt mit den verbliebenen zwei Kraftwerksstandorten und sechs,
sieben Reaktoren insgesamt, diese beiden Kernkraftwerke alleine können 50 Prozent
der derzeitigen Spitzenlast im letzten Winter erzeugen, allein an Erzeugungskapazität.
Und ja, also das ist mit ein Grund, obwohl jetzt 60,
70 Prozent der Erzeugungskapazitäten entweder besetzt wurden oder zerbombt wurden,
trotzdem noch genug Erzeugungskapazität da ist.
Und ansonsten ist man halt jetzt auch ein bisschen besser vorbereitet mit mehr
dezentraler Erzeugung.
Mehr Leute haben irgendwie Generatoren, die sie anwerfen können.
Und ja, insofern geht man davon aus,
dass die Ukraine mit dem Energiekrieg nicht in die Knie zu zwingen sein wird,
es sei denn, Russland greift die Atomkraftwerke an und schaltet deren Erzeugungskapazität aus.
So, das, weshalb jetzt auch Gerede in den russischen Propagandamedien aufgekommen ist,
man solle doch die Atomkraftwerke angreifen.
Und das steckt dahinter, dass man halt jetzt gemerkt hat, diese beiden Atomkraftwerkskomplexe
alleine reichen fast aus,
um die Ukraine vollständig oder einen Großteil der Zeit komplett mit Energie
zu versorgen und ansonsten die Hälfte der Spitzenlast ungefähr zu liefern.
Ja, ähm...
Und des Weiteren noch erwähnenswert natürlich in dem Zusammenhang ist,
dass die ukrainische Waffenproduktion, Rüstungsproduktion massiv ausgeweitet wurde.
Und wir hatten anfangs ja schon erwähnt, Modellvielfalt an Drohnen und anderen Waffensystemen.
Und wirtschaftlich gesehen sind viele kleine Manufakturen entstanden.
Sieht man auch immer die Bilder, so eine Handvoll Leute, die Drohnen zusammenschrauben
und dann verpacken. und Stapel.
So was habe ich ja auch besucht in der Ukraine, als ich da war.
Ja, wie viele Leute waren da irgendwie in dem Shop?
Zehn Leute. Ich meine, das war jetzt nicht die Manufaktur, wo die gebaut werden,
sondern das war quasi das Development Zentrum. Das war nicht identisch.
Aber mit Sicherheit ist das so. Also das ist ja gerade im Drohnenbereich unheimlich
viele Startups, die das machen und das ist ja auch ein Ein großer Vorteil des
ukrainischen Ansatzes gegenüber den Russen.
Ja, und das hat wohl dazu geführt, dass die Ukraine selbst wohl eine Million
Drohnen im letzten Jahr produziert hat auf diese Art und Weise fürs Militär.
Und das ist, ich sag mal, für Manufaktur, das ist, ich sag mal,
eine Million Drohnen, würde ich sagen, ist signifikant.
Das sind fast 3000 am Tag ungefähr,
plus sicherlich Importierte und Produkte.
Und durch diese Manufaktur viele neue Modelle, hohe Innovationsrate haben wir vorhin schon gesehen,
wobei jetzt für die Zukunft erwartet wird,
dass sich diese Innovationsrate verlangsamt und dass jetzt eine Konsolidierung
stattfindet und es dann mehr größere Produktionsanlagen oder eine Konzentration
auf weniger bewährte Modelle gibt.
Es gibt also auch weniger Modelle, die sich bewährt haben.
Das wird zumindest vorhergesagt. Und eben auch natürlich eine weitere Professionalisierung
in Richtung Militär drohen, die dann wahrscheinlich etwas teurer und aufwendiger auch sein werden,
aber auch eben entsprechend leistungsfähiger.
Und was man jetzt ja schon gesehen hat, ja, es ist krass.
Dass Hubschrauber die Drohnen, die Hubschrauber zerstören können,
Drohnen, die Minen legen,
andere Drohnen aussetzen, im Verbund fliegen, Feuerspucken und so weiter.
Ja, aber es sind nicht nur tatsächlich jetzt im Drohnenbereich,
sondern es gibt auch des Weiteren die sogenannte Bodana.
Das ist eine selbstfahrende Radtaubitze,
also eine riesige Kanone auf einen
LKW geschraubt, so wie die CISA beispielsweise im NATO-Kaliber 155 mm.
Und das Bemerkenswerte ist, dass die Ukraine das Fahrzeug und das Geschütz selbst produziert.
Und ist jetzt seit anderthalb Jahren im Einsatz, seit Frühjahr 23.
Und die Ukraine produziert bis zu zehn Stück im Monat davon.
Das heißt, die sind jetzt auch in tatsächlich signifikanter Menge vorhanden.
Also so 50 bis 100 Stück mittlerweile.
Und die Beschaffung wurde unter anderem auch von Dänemark mitfinanziert.
Das heißt, das ist das Modell, Dänemark beispielsweise gibt Geld und dann ist
jetzt 18 oder 19 von den Dingern zu bauen und die machen das dann und dann kriegt die Ukraine das.
Und jetzt werden wohl auch Gelder aus eben den Zinsen beschlagnahmter russischer
Assets dafür eingesetzt, um unter anderem eben auch Bogdanas zu finanzieren.
Also insofern finanzieren die Russen,
wenn man so will, die ukrainische Rüstungsindustrie und deren Aufbau.
Und Artilleriegranaten bauen sie ja mittlerweile auch selber in der Produktion.
Also sie produzieren schon und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie massiv die Produktion
auch aufbauen, aber ich habe da noch keine Zahlen gehört,
wie sehr ihnen das gelungen ist, also in welchem Maße sie selber Artilleriemunition
jetzt produzieren können.
Da sind sie ja noch sehr auch vom Ausland abhängig.
Ja, allerdings gibt es auch dort jetzt ganz viele,
ich sag mal auch kleine Rüstungsbetriebe und Manufakturen, so die vorher, keine Ahnung,
Metallteile für irgendwas,
für Zäune hergestellt haben oder Autoteile hergestellt haben,
die halt jetzt dann auch Granaten herstellen oder Teile von Granaten und das
sind dann auch so teilweise kleinere Shops,
die dann aber auch so 10.000 kleinere Mörsergranaten im Monat raushauen.
Ein Shop.
Also da kommt mit Sicherheit jetzt, ja, also da kommt auf jeden Fall nennenswert was zusammen und.
Was jetzt auch geplant ist, also Rheinmetall investiert nennenswert in der Ukraine,
weshalb jetzt Russland auch wohl angeblich den CEO ermorden will von Rheinmetall.
Es gab ja auch verdächtige Explosionen in zwei verschiedenen Rheinmetallbetrieben,
aber jedenfalls hält Rheinmetall jetzt 51 Prozent der neuen Rheinmetall Ukrainian
Defense Network, Network LLC,
GmbH, und investiert halt dort vor allem so in Reparatureinrichtungen in der
Westukraine, vor allem für Westpanzer jetzt und Westkanonen und so.
Dann besagte 155 mm Artilleriegranatenproduktion findet auch mit Rheinmetallbeteiligung
statt und geplant ist die Produktion des Schützenpanzers Lynx in der Ukraine.
So, das findet zwar noch nicht statt, aber ist eben auch erklärt.
Und wohl diese größere Rüstungsproduktion oder generelle Rüstungsproduktion
findet wohl zunehmend jetzt unterirdisch in Bunkern statt, aus natürlich guten Gründen.
Plus aber dann eben verteilt in wiederum kleinen Workshops.
Ja, also das wäre es jetzt wirtschaftlich.
Russland wird tendenziell schlechter,
Ukraine im Moment wird erwartet,
wird tendenziell besser, was das Wachstum angeht und bemerkenswert,
dass überhaupt dort Wachstum unter diesen Bedingungen stattfinden kann,
während in Deutschland gerade nicht so richtig wächst.
Ich meine das Wachstum hängt, wie du schon gesagt hast, sehr davon ab,
dass eben auch weiterhin so eine Kapitalunterstützung da ist,
aber grundsätzlich, das wollte ich ja vorhin auch nochmal betonen und ich betone es nochmal,
weil das muss man sich glaube ich auch mal klar machen, Ukraine ist eigentlich
ein potenzielles Powerhouse für Europa.
Also wir können uns eigentlich gar nichts mehr wünschen, als dass sie der NATO
und auch vor allem natürlich der EU beitreten.
Das wird nicht ohne Konflikte ablaufen und das haben wir bei den anderen Osterweiterungen
auch schon gespürt, dass dann eben auch einfach mal Gesellschaften aufeinandertreffen,
die in manchen Punkten dann vielleicht doch mal ganz andere Ansichten haben.
Aber so ist das halt nun mal in einem Einigungsprozess.
Den muss man irgendwann auch mal beginnen, weil sonst kommt man nicht irgendwo an.
Mittlerweile finde ich es, ich finde es immer wieder bemerkenswert,
muss man sich auch mal klar machen, wie sehr sich Frankreich und Deutschland
mal auf die Mütze gegeben haben und wie sehr diese Rivalität eigentlich gar kein Thema ist.
Und ähnlich wird man sich auch mit Polen einigen können über längere Zeit und
diese Prozesse müssen einfach nur begonnen werden.
Aber die Ukraine ist halt in vielerlei Hinsicht einfach auch eine Gelegenheit
für Europa, sich dort auch nochmal zu erweitern.
Ich finde es auch nach wie vor als eine Verpflichtung, uns dort zu engagieren,
also rein aus moralischen Gründen.
Aber es ist eben auch ein wirtschaftliches Argument, was man hier machen kann.
Das ist für uns alle nur gut und deswegen...
Lass uns weiterhin die Ukraine unterstützen in ihrem Kampf gegen Russland,
weil es ist vor allem ein Kampf von Russland gegen uns alle und das ist mir
einfach nicht recht. Ich finde das einfach unangemessen.
Und ich finde diesen Gedankengang, dass wenn wir den Krieg beenden wollen,
wir Putin davon überzeugen müssen, dass er den Krieg nicht gewinnen kann,
den finde ich nachvollziehbar.
Und in dem Moment, wo Putin zu der Erkenntnis gelangt, dass er den Krieg nicht
gewinnen kann, wird er ihn beenden.
Oder falls Putin nicht zu der Erkenntnis gelangt, aber alle anderen um ihn herum
zu der Erkenntnis gelangen, dann werden diese den Krieg beenden.
Oder Putin beenden.
Ja, einschließlich den Krieg, einschließlich Putin beenden.
Und ja, wie überzeugen wir Putin jetzt davon, dass er den Krieg nicht gewinnen kann?
Ich denke, am ehesten, indem wir langfristig Zusagen machen,
in den Aufbau der Ukraine investieren, weil was die Ukraine hat, das hat sie.
Und ja, einfach die Unterstützung weiter hochfahren und hochfahren und hochfahren,
bis Putin zu der Erkenntnis gelangt,
dass das nicht funktionieren wird.
Und dass es einfach zu teuer wird.
Und auf jeden Fall gelangen wir nicht auf dem Wege dahin, in dem man der Ukraine
völlig sinnfreie Einschränkungen auferlegt,
was die Nutzung von Waffen betrifft.
Angeht, die es bekommt. Das ist schon so ein bisschen unerhört eigentlich.
Ich meine, ja, wenn die Ukraine jetzt sagen würde, wir wollen damit russische
Krankenhäuser und Schulen bombardieren, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass man sagt, ey Leute, so haben wir aber nicht gerechnet.
Aber zu sagen, naja, also dieses Militärdepot in Russland oder diese Truppenansammlung,
die dürft ihr jetzt nicht mit unseren Waffen bekämpfen, so das macht für mich
einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Zumal wir ja schon gesehen haben, was von russischen roten Linien zu halten ist.
Und ich frage mich manchmal, wie merkbefreit muss man eigentlich sein,
dass man immer wieder auf dieses Gerede von Putin hereinfällt.
Vielleicht ist man auch einfach nur gut finanziert von Putin.
Das kann natürlich auch sein. Wir wissen es nicht.
Gut, ich würde sagen, an der Stelle beenden wir diese Sendung. Die war lang genug.
Ich dachte nicht, dass es wieder so lange wird, aber es gibt dann doch wieder viel zu erzählen.
Ja.
Wir beobachten die Situation weiterhin für euch und auch für uns.
Ja, machen das ja auch ein bisschen für uns, aber versuchen trotzdem irgendwie
alles halbwegs gewissenhaft hier aufzusammeln, was so der Wege kommt.
Insofern, muss ich sagen, verabschieden wir uns und melden uns dann demnächst
wieder, wenn wir der Meinung sind, jetzt müsste man mal wieder mal eine Sendung machen.
Ja, macht's gut, haltet die Uhren steif, bis demnächst.
Bis dann, ciao.